thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
today it's all about who will take that
final spot into the aim chance rapid
Grand Final to challenge Magnus Carlsen
will it be the so solid Wesley or will
it be the resilience of iterizaga or
perhaps The Genius of not a back it's
going to be a big day of Chess get the
popcorn ready day four Starts Now
[Music]
a car response it's Bobby spots it
we see reaction
oh no Magnus Mouse left this is a
game-ending move he's so good he's so
good at thinking on the flight
oh my goodness that's a move for you
right there think this is the craziest
position I think we've seen on the tour
this season
[Music]
it's a judgment day in the elimination
bracket three players only one will
survive and all roads lead to Magnus
Carlsen and to guide you safely through
all the moves in the studio Grand Master
David Howell Ginger Jam
Simon Williams and international Master
Danny Ranch
David what a winner final we had
fantastic chess what was the big
takeaway for you yeah Tanya it was
simply a feast of Chess yesterday for me
the Highlight was the final between
Magnus Carson and no deck address tour
of but all of the matches were so close
so tense and there was so much drama
fantastic domination there by Magnus
Carlsen Simon his
that's right I mean uh it's something
that we all must do and sometimes we get
quite annoyed with our opponents and we
just want to tell them just resign and
how many times I want to say that to my
opponent so we're I'm wearing the just
resigned t-shirt today I love it I love
it should we should we do the drink
water game every time Simon says just
resign we might want to do that one
water is great for you so it's good to
stay hydrated during the shows but uh
talking with Magnus today he mentioned
that maybe there was a saga a sequel
that could be you need to resign you
need to resign to add to just resign and
you know what the most surreal thing was
Danny I I tuned in to watch one of uh
magnus's streams and he was wearing this
t-shirt and I was like my God it's my
face or the world champions t-shirt I'm
like what is going on so that was that
was really weird yeah we did have some
Epic
battles in the losers quarterfinal
yesterday's before it was the Magnus
Carlton show
80 pieces if you're King what is this
I'm saying he gives up the night but he
gets Black's key dot Square Bishop is
this gonna backfire oh my God five
seconds for that he made the last one
with just two seconds on the clock
love shakes his head and makes a movie
just one second on the clock
and that's Checkmate on the board Edward
he goes through he has knocked out love
on our onion
the house is coming down I think
10 seconds and it doesn't even matter
you could have an hour on your clock
against Magnus in this position Magnus
will still perhaps take it yep
[Music]
oh very nice forces the Rooks off
get out of here it's just too it's
good Magnus Carlsen shows who's boss
with the black pieces wins round one
another back which is 25 seconds on the
clock down two pawns now in the position
but he does pick up a key Central Pawn
26 yeah four seconds and look at it he
reacts he knows he's made a mistake he
goes back first mistake of the game in
terms of uh practical play there he just
lost a pawn with gain of tempo he didn't
he lost on time yeah he's losing right
here
loses on the clock
[Music]
it was an emotional roller coaster we
started on Monday with eight players
four made it to through the winners a
semi-finals while Wesley Seoul fedocia
veterizaga and Jordan van for his drop
down to the losers bracket we also had a
fantastic winners final but we not back
up to satrov and Magnus Carlson Magnus
Carlsen is two to the Grand Final he
gets arrested we went on to see
it is a lot on the line the players who
make it through to the losers final also
book a spot in division one of the next
Champions chest Tour event we've seen
Danny how much this means to Eduardo
trizaga is this something that's going
to be on the back of his mind today I
think it has to be we know the whole
thing means so much to him and if you
missed that interview check it out but
getting to the losers final getting past
Wesley so would probably already be a
dream come true right it guarantees him
another chance at the top division which
is the only direct way to get to Toronto
since we can now say that's where the
live final is so
eturizaga knows just how much his career
has the potential to continue to be on a
great trajectory if he can get by Wesley
today yeah I think we all want that
fairy tale to come true sometimes and
that really is uh the fairy tale finish
for Eduardo uh to to win a couple of
games a couple of matches and get to the
final I mean it was such a moving
interview you've all got to watch it I
mean I think it nearly had us all in
tears here so uh it was it was fantastic
so I yeah I just wish him the best of
luck today yeah it's going to be tough
for you to rizaga though Wesley so he's
been here so many times before he's done
it before he's really good in those
clutch moments and it feels like he's
turned his tournament around but whoever
it is whether it's up to sator of so or
to rasaga who qualified to play Magnus
we're in for some great chess
it is going to be a great chess Westie
still one of the hardest players to beat
on the circuit but a very hungry
iterizaga there's a lot on the line not
just in division one division two also
heats up with so much at stake
Vision Two delivered one of the most
exciting matches of the tournament
American Sam sevian and got akamski
battled it out with nothing but decisive
results in their semi-final showdown in
the end it was seven who came out on top
in Armageddon kamski just not enough
time to uh to win the position in an
interesting turn of events Amin tap it
to buy forfeited his semi-final match
against Dennis lazovic likely due to
scheduling conflicts savian and lazovic
are now set to face off in the winners
bracket Final in 3 Yang Yi Yu defeated
Tuan Min Lei 2-0 a one-sided match you
punched his ticket to the Grand Final in
style big names remain alive in the
losers bracket will Redemption be earned
we're soon to find out
[Music]
and to guide us through division two and
three also in the studio woman Grand
Master Kathy satsala Chevrolet carry so
many decisive games fantastic battles
and a lot at stake today in the winners
final that's right Tanya once again this
on the steak we have the ticket to the
division one for the next event and 10
000 USA dollars and we do have two
winner two players in the winners
bracket and this is Dennis lazovic and
Sam savian yesterday Dennis lazavik had
an easy day because his opponent Amin
savitabai has not show up but today Sam
will for sure show up 22 years old
Grandmaster from USA he was once
youngest Grandmaster of USA at the age
of 13 and 10 months and there are also
matches in the elimination bracket of
division two now Katie you mentioned the
big ten thousand dollars and of course
they qualify for the next uh Champions
chest or event division one now 10K for
a player like Magnus might not mean so
much but for these youngsters Fighting
For That Glory it's a lot of money
that's right Tanya it can be a very good
chance for them to maybe get seconds or
coaches or maybe even just plan one
whole year of over the board tournament
and to play and get more and more
experience
who will shine in division two there is
a lot on the line for these young
prodigies fighting it out but not just
in division two we've got big names in
division three as well that's right so
we have you Yankee Chinese super Grand
Master he will not play today because
he's already in the finals but we do
have a lot of big names like Mama Dev or
Dominguez and they will fight now in the
losers bracket and will Face Tomorrow
You Yankee here we have 5 000 USA
dollars first price and they are
fighting for it
wow super Grand Masters there fighting
it out in all these three divisions and
you can catch the action on chess dojo's
twitch Channel as well as chess.com
events we will closely be following all
the action in division one and it's all
a fight to get to that Grand Final
against Magnus Carlsen one of the
players in the race Eduardo iterizaga
he's already one hot and it all started
with his performance in the planes
incremental records
[Laughter]
foreign
he has won several open events in the
Chess World he also is six-time national
champion in two different countries and
that's not something many chess players
can boast about also an Olympic medalist
but this one just means so much to him
fighting it out against all the big boys
of online chess and the Chess World he
took down love on our onion yesterday
can he keep up his big run Simon what
will it take for itrazaga to take down
Wesley saw
it's going to be tough right I mean
Wesley is a phenomenal player when
Wesley's on top form he's really hard to
beat
um and I think what Eduardo needs to do
is just try to mix things up a little
bit you know try to complicate the
position I think if he goes into two
standard kind of positions Wesley's
gonna be very bit more experienced than
him and know what to do so try to mess
it up a little bit try to attack and I
think it's big chances when they both
maybe get shorter time uh he proved
yesterday he's very good in those real
moments where they only have like a
minute left so fingers crossed we have a
great match
I love the little instant replay of all
the different celebrations of eturi saga
right now if you're not a fan of this
guy like what is wrong with you at this
point right but I want to highlight one
key point I agree that Wesley is the
favorite in this match and I've been
saying I've been watching his Forum turn
around but a two-game match is very
different than four games or six games
do not be surprised if ichirizaga takes
this home but the better player often
needs more games to flex and to and to
adjust and to show things and so even if
so is objectively the stronger player
ichirisaga has the momentum he seems to
have the universe he's got his mom he's
got everything working for him right now
and I am so excited to see this match
yeah it's a two-game shootout and uh on
any given day the underdog can Thrive
and uh we saw itsurersaga celebrating
that he also turned up what was it more
than half an hour early for his game for
35 minutes before the timestamp this is
uh it's herizaga just true professional
fully focused fully ready and uh he
wants to fight he wants to fight and the
fact that he came so early the first
player to arrive for that loses
semi-final just shows how hungry and
ambitious he is for his match against uh
Wesley so today here Simon tell us what
are their Styles like
uh well they're Universal I mean at this
uh at this level you have to have a
universal style but uh Wesley likes
traditional openings he likes E4 he
plays this really quite normally and
well extremely well and I'd say Eduardo
is a bit more sort of sidelining so he
prefers signing super aggressive uh and
when he gets the chance he just loves
attacking so he's got he's got to like
grasp onto that and just go for Wesley's
neck you know just go straight in kill
that would be my advice and mate Wesley
that's right that's the one it's going
to be a clash of styles which means it's
going to be a lot of fun for us let's
take a look at their aim chess stats
what are there's Trends and weaknesses
David what does this tell us about the
fights that's coming up it shows that
the fight is going to be a tough one
actually we see some really impressive
stats from both players but uh iterizaga
we've got to admire his Advantage
capitalization that means he wins 92
percent of games where he has a
significant advantage and he's extremely
resourceful to fighting back 51 of the
time even when he's down on the position
we should mention however that Wesley
overall is a bit more accurate total
accuracy than 91 that's extremely high
so the longer the games go on the more
matches there are as Danny said
that might shine through yeah I think
that seriously we saw some similar stats
between Notre back and Magnus where
Notre back even Edge magnets out a
little bit in terms of the aim chess
overall kind of evaluation but in total
accuracy you see so has the edge there
for a reason but again it's two games
anybody could take it right and if we
get Armageddon which is kind of what I'm
rooting for I I don't know who would
prefer white there because uh eternity
zaga might want white and a chance to be
super aggressive and go for it yeah I
think the first game is going to be key
isn't it I mean and we can hear the
countdown now I mean it's very exciting
but if Eduardo gets up to a good start
dreams can come true
it is a dream matchup for us and the
players are fighting to get into the
Grand Final and it's only a best of two
the players start with 15 minutes get a
three second increment with every move
they make one and a half points is the
minimum winning margin and the winner
goes on to the losers final booking
their Spot Not only in the aim chess
rapid Grand Final but also division one
of the next Champions chest Star Event
while the loser will be eliminated
Wesley so with the global championship
trophy behind him is ready to go he did
win and convincing style in the losers
quarterfinal and look at that Eduardo
buttoning up his shirt he's ready for
the action and he means business when he
logged in early we saw the time stamp as
David was pointing out maybe that also
showed some nerves or maybe it was that
he logged in early so that he could go
shower and change because it does kind
of look his hair's a little wet right
he's got a new shirt on that he did when
he first joined so perhaps he was
joining to to make sure he took care of
that so that he could get real fresh in
Focus now yeah look good feel good
that's uh how the saying goes and it's a
sicilian and uh Wesley small Shake of
the head there I'm not sure what that
was about uh maybe not expecting the
Sicilian but Simon you mentioned to
tourism he plays uncompromising chess on
compromising openings and this is
shaping up nicely no kind of solid slow
Italians here and fincato by Wesley
although the G3 is a solid attempt by
Wesley to maybe take it out of the
sharpest lines of the open Sicilian
sorry Simon go ahead yeah and I agreed I
mean I I think G3 is a wise choice from
Wesley I mean there's many ways you can
play the position but G3 is a more
positional founded move and I think the
longer the game goes on uh I would say
the the better Wesley's chances get
because he is the more experienced
player at the highest levels so uh it's
going to be very interesting and I'm
happy to see a sicilian at least
interesting approach there by Wesley so
with the G3 against the Sicilian many
ways to play the Sicilian but Wesley
choosing to play his opponent we've been
talking about the aggressive attacking
chaotic style of Eduardo trisaga Wesley
making sure he doesn't go into any of
those uh crazy messy Sicilian Waters to
navigate and I want
I want you Danny here it's a best of two
and this is something you've been saying
right in a longer match the better
player on paper usually would take it
away best of two anything can happen but
having white in the first game is that
perhaps a little bit of an advantage I
think it definitely is I think the
things we know about Chad still hold up
which is having the advantage of the
first move uh plays out on any level but
especially at the top and especially
seeing what's Happening Here note that
Wesley has just as much time that than
that which he started with right
including the increment and Eternity
Saga already not necessarily uh thrown
off remember he's a Grand Master of the
highest level so he knows his openings
but this definitely suggests that he
wasn't prepared because these guys don't
take time because their coaches tell
them to slow down anymore right they've
matured past that as as players right
they they only take time when they need
to and so already plus one for Wesley in
terms of his choice in terms of the
position he might get on the board to
avoid the sharpest lines in the open
Sicilians yeah why it's called his King
castled Wesley is still really flexible
with his Queen side pieces so I'm liking
how he's set up here uh and the opening
choice I would uh yeah I would say
actually the kind of thought process has
changed especially with the rise of
online chess these kind of long knockout
matches because historically a lot of
players would have preferred to chose to
choose black first that way they see how
the game unfolds and they know when they
have white in the final game how
aggressive to be how to strike but it
feels like these players these days
players really back themselves and
they're really confident with white they
just know that if they get that score
then
psychologically it's a huge blow yeah
with just two games there is no margin
for error in the elimination bracket and
this big thing by Eduardo terzaga after
the move that we just saw with Wesley
fiance shattering his uh Bishop does
that mean that the opening battle has
been won by Wesley Simon
I am I think it's a bit early to say I
mean this position should be roughly
even it's been played thousands upon
thousands of times before uh neither
side can really claim an advantage but I
think it's it shows what having this we
call it the serve really like the serve
in tennis is the same as having the
white pieces you can kind of dictate the
game and you can sort of draw it into
the kind of style that you want that is
the real Advantage having white uh it's
not getting Advantage always it's not
getting you know it's trying to get the
positions you enjoy playing and I think
that's what Wesley has done here he's
getting into position he's going to
enjoy playing more than Eduardo so uh we
can already see Eduardo's and playing a
little bit slowly here and um you know
he's got to adjust to this but I was
going to highlight that I really liked
eduara's response we see then Wesley
went on the clock and the reason is
Eduardo chose this queen C7 move order
for a reason because it prevented the
most the most common the most logical
path forward which is with C4 David's
already highlighting it so a great Point
Simon agree White's often choosing
something that even if it doesn't get an
advantage anymore because of computer
prep it's a position you know but
awesome awesome nod to Eduardo he chose
Queen C7 Wesley was then taken aback
took almost 90 seconds on the move
before playing B3 because Wesley didn't
let him get the most well sorry Eduardo
didn't let him get the wheels to know
well I can't speak today the most
well-known roads David yep uh the most
well-known and maybe the most uh
profitable rotor if you can get a Pawn
on C4 it's what we call the maroxy bind
and this Pawn structure we've seen it
numerous times actually throughout the
tournament it has tended to favor white
uh just because you have a bit more
space this is a nice Pawn chain and
these two pawns prevent a breakout so at
least an easy breakout for black that's
why the players have been investing a
bit of time they know that this Pawn
structure is likely but Eduardo is
mulling over his options is there a way
to stop this the answer might just be no
if you can't stop this then you just
have to get developed to get castled and
we'll see that type of Hedgehog
formation that we've seen several times
already I agree but again he couldn't
stop it anyway right so he made sure the
move order was is a little awkward and
when you force the B3 move in these
positions I played some of these Knight
or shenanigan kind of structures as
black you're also maybe committing white
a little bit right because that Bishop
doesn't have to feed in keto in a maroxy
blind structure if white just got C4
Knight C3 it can go to G5 it can go to
E3 right so B3 is a move that's either a
wasted Tempo or you commit the bishop to
that diagonal and so again there's just
these are heavyweight Fighters right
there's footwork going on here and
they're both trying to get a favorable
middle game even if white has an edge
objectively
and there we go Wesley does indeed put
the pawn on C4 and iterizaga castles
very quickly yeah still in the balance
it's just I think at that point you
mentioned Simon it's just who's more
comfortable I've seen a tourism play
these types of setups before several
times so despite the fact he spent three
and a half minutes already I don't think
he's that devastated that it's this Pawn
structure but yeah it's just about
whether Wesley can slowly squeeze him I
think we're lucky to have our expert
aren't we in the in these positions on
the panel when the Tanya you were giving
us some great advice when it was uh
nordie Beck who had a similar structure
uh to this against Magnus yesterday so
uh you you know all the Maneuvers here
and you'd like the black pieces right I
do you got that one right I have played
this position with black and I have to
say that when you go through these kind
of we call them Tylenol pulse and
structures with the black pieces facing
the fiancato that Wesley has done on the
king side is not exactly uh your dream
because what black wants is the place
that light squared Bishop on B7 you want
to Target that Direct but right now
that's very difficult because there are
always tactics on the board with the
e-pawn pushing forward and then the
diagonal opens up and you're the one
who's in trouble first so uh the other
question for black here to answer is
where do you want to develop your knight
now space is such a big Concept in chess
very often in the maroxy bind White's
the one with a lot of space so what you
want to do is trade pieces as black so
you've got less pieces to jump around
with a little space you've got so Knight
C6 would be something that I would be
considering David as you're pointing out
just trying to get rid of one of the
pair of minor pieces another approach is
obviously you can jump to the D7 Square
get the Knight to the center uh point on
C5 so even though Wesley's approach is a
solid one out of the opening it's uh got
its own Pros here because it doesn't let
black achieve what you really want as a
sicilian player great stuff I'm learning
a lot you see this is brilliant
masterclass you would say you you
actually would prefer to face the type
of approach that Magnus played against
Notre break yesterday with the more
aggressive developed Bishop with F4 with
G4 so someone who plays these systems
you're actually more comfortable with
that attack than you are facing okay
that's that's uh really good stuff and I
think that's the reason we're seeing
Eduardo use so much of his time I don't
think he was expecting Wesley to go in
with the this setup that he's chosen for
white and it's a really smart move by
Wesley
yeah and this uh this maroxy bind with
white pawns on e4 it's always signified
by that uh often there's been a trade of
one pawns it kind of rise from a whole
bunch of openings right Tanya the
Sicilian you can arise from the English
opening the reti um so it's always
signified by white having this kind of
bind uh this grip that we say with those
pawns on light squares and blacks just
struggles to break out on the light
squares if you can't break out as we saw
yesterday and actually as we saw with uh
I think aronian losing a game as well
earlier in the tournament then you tend
to suffer as black so that's why tourism
now in the tank for two minutes he wants
to break the bind he wants to lash out
but it's not easy yeah I mean personally
I I gave up playing Sicilians where I
allowed my opponent to get the structure
so there's many ways you can try to get
a sicilian position as black but uh
personally and again this is this is uh
of what kind of taste you like but I
hated playing this kind of position as
black because you you generally have to
be very patient you generally have to
wait for your chance and it's hard to
know when to break and you you know
patience is maybe not my forte
um so it's a personal choice though
Danny do we think something like this
what you know the kind of opening you
like but
um mainly I also tend to play these
systems more for black like like Tanya
and I completely agree with everything
she said about it being way more
irritating when you're facing the bishop
on the longest diagonal but we only have
one game to look at David so I wanted to
maybe bring up the analysis board and
help help set the tone for the audience
because we all kind of jumped into the
fact that this is a bind assuming
everyone knows that but maybe highlight
again the fundamental things going on
here because it's going to tell the
story for the rest of the game E4 C4
what black wants to do with D5 and B5 if
they could and maybe just describe the
general nature because it's going to
dictate what we're talking about here
for the next 20 moves yeah uh exactly
and uh it is a very much love it or
hated type of setup Tanya loves it Simon
hates it for black but essentially black
is going to get a bit stuck and I'm
going to even give black here what they
want I'm going to ignore the fact that
E5 is winning here this rook in the
corner but for example even if black
gets a setup that they would like here
then often you are kind of Trapped in
your first two or three ranks so all of
Black's pawns all of Black's pieces will
be uh kind of camped out really solidly
ready to jump forward but you need a
break such as D5 or B5 later in order to
give your pieces some energy meanwhile
if you look at White's Army white has a
beautiful night here Nitro C3 as well
there's a lot more kind of squares
around the center a scope for pieces to
move the White Queen has a bunch of
squares to maneuver around the white
Rooks too and white can play on both
sides of the board so as Danny mentioned
D5 and B5 are the ways to break the bind
which is signified by these Pawns in the
center and if you can your pieces have
energy if they
if you can't break out then yeah you
just tend to suffer I tend to I mean
I'll take team Tanya here because I also
I mean like you you described all the
advantages for white but I would argue
the flip side of it is uh black has no
weaknesses
and white white at some point often runs
out of patience and also wants to
advance with F4 or either E5 or F5 and
and these Bishops are waiting to sort of
pounce if you play moves like if we play
for black real quick moves that like
rook d8 and Rook C8 Tonya highlighted
like we'll play Queen E2 yeah Rook C8
Tanya highlighted this plan yesterday
which is there's Bishop f8 at some point
and you kind of re-double fee and keto
there's Queen to B8 and queen A8 and you
put the queen on this long diagonal and
a battery and you just sort of sit and
wait and again it's a it is a choice of
style right it's a preference uh of of
how you want to play the position but
these are hyper modern positions
designed to be full of tension so that
when when they explode your pieces are
in the right spot and you can get
tactics so objectively white is better
the engines love the space you're going
to see the eval bar sitting there for a
while but
um it remains to be seen who Who cashes
in when when the moment is most critical
and it will happen the break the
explosion in the position will happen
and then it'll come down to whose pieces
are ready for it we do see a little bit
of a Time Edge there and I want to get
in our room game expert into this
because
Eduardo there with a very plain simple
background Wesley on the other hand now
on Monday the uh Simon when we started
he lost to Nada back and it was a
different room but since he's been
winning we've been seeing him uh Play
From Here is he superstitious what's
going on there I'm glad that I'm now the
Grand Master of rooms or backing rooms
and I mean I have to say Eduardo's room
doesn't give much away does it but I I
do like the way he's put on a nice white
shirt that that shows that he means
business you know maybe he's taking
Wesley to the funeral taking him down
and Wesley has changed rooms yeah I mean
he started playing very badly uh for him
Wesley and now he's in this new room
it's a bit of the karma what's that
thing Shay is that how you say it you
know yeah yeah where you've got to put
stuff in the right area to feel the
Vibes you know a little bit of
meditation maybe that's what Wesley's
doing here you know getting the right
Karma running through his body
um and I don't really know what else to
say about it Wesley we also know he's
playing on a secret lab sharing and we
can't show but I did show Tanya the
picture of the fair play cam yes but
Wesley has crunched over a secret lab
chair as a desk and he likes it it looks
like a back problem to me a back problem
in the future for Wesley with with what
he's doing right now that was a very
creative way of actually playing I
haven't seen uh a player actually play
online chess like that but it seems to
be working well for Wesley ever since he
has shifted into this room and with the
secret lab chair uh handling his laptop
there and we see a bit of a think here
Wesley has slowed down after a natural
developing move David what's going on
why is he taking such a long think yeah
I'm slightly bemused here as to why
Wesley has spent three and a half almost
four minutes now on this one turn maybe
he's just deciding where to put white
start Square Bishop Danny you mentioned
often you can choose three or four
different logical homes for it but is it
that critical a decision right now it
looks like you can just develop and
continue Black's next move has been
telegraphed essentially it is is going
to bring his Knight to C6 next move okay
Wesley eventually playing the most
natural move in the position but uh it
must be now that Wesley was investing
his time on this decision whether to
trade-off nights or whether to retreat
black is a bit cramped with this
Hedgehog formation so usually you want
to keep as many pieces on the board if
you're white uh when you have that space
Advantage but no he just moves his Rook
to the center actually there's a semi
threat here that Tanya pointed out
yesterday in a similar position but yeah
it's strange to play Such natural moves
after such a long tank uh let maybe we
can show the okay pieces are off the
board here and I think this does benefit
black long term Tanya will correct me as
the expert here if I'm wrong but there
was a threat for example if black had
moved the Rook you could see the night
land on D5 just watch out for this one
uh in all moroxy bind Hedgehog type of
positions um it's after a temporary
sacrifice this night is pinned and white
will regain the material uh with
interest next turn simply taking this
Knight next move so okay the knights are
off the board and Tanya what do you
think black is gonna do the Hedgehog
here is it prickly are it spikes are it
spikes ready here if white lashes out I
think it's uh it's like that Hedgehog
that's curled up right now but when
white starts overextending with the
pawns which we can expect at some point
uh blacks getting the Army ready to
become all um all full of Pricks at that
point but I want to highlight what you
just mentioned also David the trade of
the knights it does favor Black because
again it comes down to the concept of
space it's clear the pawn structure
determines that Black's the one with
less space here you want to try and
trade off as many pieces as possible
that's just old traditional chess wisdom
that holds true now again the one
problem for black is that black can't
challenge that light squared Bishop just
yet the tactics that you pointed out
would be on the board if black had
chosen the other Square for the bishop
than the one that just that Wesley
Chesley Chesley
the freudian's foot there Chesley good
name not justly has gone far with the
bishop falling back to E8 and I think
he's eyeing those breaks that you guys
have been talking about trying to get
either D5 in or b5n once that Queen is
out of that pressure on c-line yeah yeah
yeah I think H3 is played in these
positions one it's like a high-class
waiting move uh as Grandmaster
jermolinski wants going to a move like
that you want to play for G4 in some
positions and there's a battery if we
want to highlight the bishop on B2 yeah
and the Queen on D4 David's all over it
we complete each other's
sandwiches there we go okay I just
tested you and G4 is coming with G5
coming the Knight doesn't have the E8
square and these are the little
subtleties in these structures because
obviously the attorney Saga avoided that
Knight D5 trick by not putting the
bishop on C6 but by putting it on E8 it
takes away a score for the Knight so
these are the things we're going to
build up to and don't be surprised if
you see G4 at the right time for Wesley
probably maybe not with a king on H2
there could be some discover checks but
um
as you pointed out this Knight is pretty
much stuck here you can never Retreat it
it might look like you want to put your
Bishop on the long diagonal but now
white tonight will always jump out the
way yeah move like Knight D5 and this
battery means that Queen takes G7
Checkmate is a winning threat and white
will most likely win material so uh yeah
a few small tactics here to justify
these strategic decisions and meanwhile
it's rosargo's queen as Tanya predicted
it is off the C file and white drops
back as well free kg stuff and is there
a big threat on the board right now
David I can smell some tactics again
it's always the same move in the
Sicilian Magnus dropped that Knight on
D5 last turn and ah let's jump back into
the board this is lovely no it's a
tactic you got to be aware of right
because it's a common pattern in these
positions sorry Simon go ahead no I can
see what you guys are gonna try I mean I
I'd love to play B5 here right I mean
this is this is a break I'd love to try
and maybe when I look at the evaluation
bar not as much as I would but okay
let's let's see this tactic anyway but
yeah yeah it has been dodged by a
tourism but this would be the tactic
jumping out the way and they say lpdo
loose pieces drop off this White Queen
is now attacking a loose piece the black
queen and if the black queen trades off
or moves then you can flick in an
Intermezzo you can flick in a check
first taking this bishop and at the very
least here you can just take this queen
I'm wondering if there are some cool
tactics probably you just take and this
end game is going to be favorable for
white actually maybe a few I was going
to say Bishop A3
man almost you lose having materials
there wow nice is that what lpdo means I
thought that was a boy band in the 90s
lpdo I think it was too late get with it
Danny okay lpdo
lose pieces drop off yeah that sounds
like a great boy band name by the way
she has boy band
let's start it it could be lead singer
but I was just thinking who would be in
the ideal perfect chess boy band oh God
I mean that is that's for the chat
because we can have a look we can have a
long chat about this I mean you've got
to have one of the chest bras you've got
to have oh okay I'll just uh yeah let's
get back to the chest I've avoided this
tactic of 95 it also opens up the threat
at some point potentially of Knight G4
it would just be a check and pots or C
check pots or play check don't just give
checks for no reason
um but it also prevents G4 right so the
but I will say this is a little
reminiscent of levonne aronian's Queen
slide that got him in trouble against
the turizaga you have to be careful when
the uh when Mom goes and plays with the
kids on the playground right um she
can't do the monkey bars anymore and as
the Tactics get flying uh you can get in
trouble there so
92 that's what I mean there's some
that's my very vague way of saying maybe
92 even if you just put the king back on
G1 the queen isn't comfortable there
it's a dangerous spot it feels like a
blitz move maybe a rapid move you just
want to hint at some threats put the
fear of ghosts into your opponent but
yeah it could backfire definitely and uh
I've I'm always skeptical of Queen moves
like this when a queen is kind of doing
all the work on her own and white has no
weaknesses really
so yeah I'm on board with you there
Danny but it has forced Wesley so to
tank for two minutes now and that's a
promising sign whenever I see these
sorry David go on sorry I was just
saying the clocks are Level now clocks
are level and these kind of positions
they always feel like boiling water
right it takes a while and it's heating
up slowly and slowly but it's getting
there and then finally a break happens
and
the water goes everywhere yeah it just
goes everywhere so even though it feels
like a slow strategic fight right now
these positions are so rich that
eventually one on the side tries to
tries to extend
especially it just uh explodes and blows
open completely and the last move by
Wesley targeting a weakness that's quite
nicely protected David yeah a bit
strange to me he's not immediately
hitting the D6 Pawn because White's
Queen despite the fact white is
attacking uh black spawn on D6 three
times White's Queen is a bit in the way
uh you kind of want the heavy pieces
behind but he's at least reminding it to
rizaga that there might be some threats
tactics later on to do with E5 some pins
here and there
again it feels like a to me a blitz
rapid type of move you're just hinting
at something without threatening
anything directly and it has forced into
a saga loose pieces drop off that Bishop
wasn't protected he's dropped it back I
was just going to say speaking of it
feels like a blitz rapid move I like
that move right it doesn't take a ton of
time he knows that there's nothing
concretely to do put my piece on a
protective square and I think that
that's the kind of thing that makes him
such a dangerous player in fast time
controls because there's a lot of
players who might spend a minute and a
half there and then still play Bishop f8
some of the best things that the best
players in the world do at fast time
controls is they just play quickly they
just play quickly because you know that
the critical moment hasn't arrived yet
and you're gonna need your time when
it's there so it's not that I love
Bishop evade as a move I just love how
fast he played it he's not going to
overthink himself to lose this game
go be careful your queen lamp yes you
have you both pointed out that the
positive for that bishop move is you you
take away a square that the queen might
want to get back to uh the C5 square and
uh and there's pros and cons I mean I I
do like White's position I think black
is struggling to find a plan as you do
in in these types of positions
um but the the clocks they're getting
under five minutes each and I I think as
I mentioned at the start I really think
Eduardo's best chance is in those real
Blitz scenarios I think uh not Wesley's
a fantastic Blitz player but I think
that's where the pressure could play you
know get to get to Wesley a little bit
more so
um and there's nothing happening on the
board yet so we we could get to that
very shortly you know that's a really
cool point to make and that makes me
wonder that is part of the math strategy
for Eduardo to try and take this to
Armageddon
well I think it's the underdog every
game helps him I mean honestly and and
uh the fact that there's only two games
it creases the chances but I he would be
happy to be in an Armageddon I would I
would bet especially you called out
Wesley starts with white so he turns ago
on a little bit of a disadvantage and uh
I think fast time controls and uh
Armageddon would be something he would
welcome he's already won one Armageddon
match in this event although so is
Wesley
um I by the way you mentioned that he's
a great Blitz player I want to point out
that Wesley so Wesley so as we've
measured accuracy and Blitz and this is
some stuff that we do with cheat
detection all kinds of things always
like looking into how good the players
are Wesley has only ever lost the two
players in the speeches Championship
they're named Magnus Carlson and hakara
Nakamura and Wesley is I think one of
the most underrated
accurate Blitz players in the world he
actually has put up the best performance
compared to computers in the
three-minute segments that we've ever
had so just remember that about Wesley
when he's on form
dude dude it's a dude's a tough cookie
yeah yeah it's a style of play he rarely
blinds he just doesn't make mistakes
yeah he can't I mean he calculates
extremely well I mean that's uh they
they all do but where's his calculation
is is just the it is better than
Eduardo's at the real critical moments
and he is the global trust Champion as
well for Wesley stores so uh definitely
one of the best players on the planet
but David you mentioned that you've
rarely lost an Armageddon there's one
guy who managed to do it a tourism it
was the London chess classic I was
having the tournament with my life Blitz
tournament and uh I met a tourism the
final and
it's too quick for me I started with
white bear I started with an extra
minute and I think 10 moves into the
game I was a minute down he was just
bang bang super accurate and super
confident and as we've seen throughout
this tournament he's a tricky guy so
yeah I think if it comes down to
Armageddon the it will just become a bit
more random and that suits to rizaga I
mean while this position he's trying to
make it more random Eduardo here but
Wesley's keeps shutting the door he's
just saying okay I've pushed the black
queen now to a bit of a poor Square I'm
covering all my pawns it's you you have
the burden of breaking out now and we
can see that reflected in the clock
times I mean this is this is why I can't
play these positions as black because uh
I want to play G5 right this is why I
just can't play them because I know it's
a bad move but it looks like fun
and I want to play G5 maybe put my queen
behind the pawn and uh you know I
actually Bobby Fischer did play to be
fair a similar idea in uh probably a
completely different position but it was
at least a hippopotamus uh kind of
structure where he very famous game I
think it was against off Anderson where
he he played this this Pawn push and uh
how ridiculous is that I'm sure the
answer is very but if you want to get a
bit of action Maybe
don't laugh too much people or think I'm
completely crazy it looks very loosening
right it's not it's not going to work
because White's got an E5 counter break
I think at the right moment but still
you know and if there is I got there
touching the two minute Mark uh Simon
the idea you mentioned it might be on
the board what are the chances of that
David yeah I think Simon's being too
modest I think it could well just be a
good move maybe we can get an assist
here from the engine what does the
computer suggest here for black long
long think now from a tourist Saga you
see the Panic on the camera he knows
he's Frozen he spent more than half his
time on this move he needs to speed up
yeah this is a real problem isn't it no
matter what he plays now he's put it's
the best move
[Laughter]
sometimes ah okay he's gone for the he's
gone for a more uh restrained one there
but he spent too much time there I feel
yeah I mean he spent so much time on
that move and he's got under half the
amount of time of Wesley and uh this
move is a bit more traditional and I
think again you want to get Wesleyan a
bit of a uncompromising situation same
idea though attacking that pawn in the
middle of the board
I agree but I I like your G5 better than
the position we saw here Simon so you
were being modest it was a great call
out to Fisher to that fisher game I feel
like E5 is the positional No-No you want
to avoid not because Black's position is
I don't know it's it's not even that
much worse according to the computer but
to me the D6 Pawn being backward the D5
Square belonging to Black makes these
positions a little bit less flexible
yeah D5 Square belonging to White I'm
sorry
Black's Queen is pretty much stuck on
the king side now and uh it's just
basically all the tensions switched to
one flank because you have that look uh
kind of lost that flexibility as you say
Danny but how will Wesley reposition his
pieces the White Knight looked nice and
pretty a moment ago feels like it's a
bit caught in the way now it needs to
decide which uh side to go to I love a
tourism last move again just hinting
that you might push that phone forward
every move now Wesley has to worry about
Harry stepping towards the black king
and okay he's so afraid of that that he
blocks giving up some squares uh to
trying to close down lines as much as
possible allowing this Knight check the
white King's got a step back
it's heating up though I mean just
because the time situation the position
is uh is sort of fizzling as Tanya said
as well
um my one danger I think for black
though is that okay he's got he's played
some aggressive moves but I think he
might come to a brick wall at some point
and then he might have to start going
backwards and when that occurs uh white
white has a superior
Superior positional assets here he's got
that big square that Danny pointed out
in the middle of the board D5 a major
Outpost Black's got a weak Pawn in the
middle of the board so it's kind of like
you know black needs to keep this kind
of initiative flowing uh really in this
position if you can wow or they can't be
Mind Games mind games from Wesley
there's no world he wants to draw here
he's up two and a half minutes on the
clock and and in a pretty good spot
wrestling bail out with a repetition or
does he think he has more in this
position it will make his intentions
clear and he's going for it he's going
for it the
position repeated itself twice but but
not that third magical time and Wesley
there just blinking really uh I know he
wants to win he wants to massage this
not necessarily improving his position
with this last bishop move but keeping
the game alive and the clock times I
love that movie five by eternity Saga
holding the B4 Square prevents the
knight's route to the D5 square and
again he finds it quickly he trusts
himself
he needs this to become a mutual time
scramble and not one where he's just
down two minutes on the clock 100 and uh
he I mean his time is under a minute now
you know it's worth pointing that out
but he he is changing gear and he's
changing gear and he's playing good
moves and uh you we can't really fault
many of his moves at the moment you know
uh that he he's doing everything he
needs to do now I mean I'm still looking
for these breaks I mean you know when
you've got a kind of close position like
this you've got to look for your Pawn
breaks and both sides can consider
moving their F pawns
um I I again that that comes a great
risk as well but this is the kind of
thing you must do in these positions
keep an eye out for your breaks and your
opponent's Pawn breaks
um which where's Wesley's Queen going
okay the queen steps back I was saying
it could have gone to the king side the
queen side okay repeating the position
again second time we've seen this one
what will Wesley try to keep the game
going extra minute on the clock but that
time Advantage is slipping away slowly
Eduardo really has up the base wow wow
second time we've seen this position as
well if white drops the queen back that
would have been a draw but look at that
move by the way if the Queens come off
the Knight runs out of squares and F3 is
going to trap the pony not quite on the
rim but still pretty Grim in regards to
his options there so uh that was nice
hey rhyme time I'll be here all week
good that's good good work the uh
they're refusing the queen trades this
is heating up but also the action in
division two and Katie's got a big
update for us from the winners final
that's right Sonya we do have first row
Pittsburgh and slazovic and samsabian
the Alaska slightly better position but
it ended in a draw they are playing
second game this looks equal to me I
think we might see here possible
Armageddon meanwhile uh we have um uh
another game Martinez on fire winning
first game against kamski and also
second game looks very promising for him
and meanwhile Tabata bio again no show
uh from him he plays the tournament and
his opponent goes to Define not right
away
thank you for that Kathy we will be
checking in with you throughout the day
and uh now it's all back on this big
moment with the teresaga under a minute
on the clock Wesley about to reach the
minute Mark uh the Bishops are off the
board who does that trade favor
I think it's pros and cons black was a
bit cramped SO trading pieces should
help however that was White's bad bishop
and that was Black's good Bishop now if
you compare pieces Black start Square
Bishop looks pretty sad to me what do
you guys think I totally agree um that
there are pros and cons black gets more
space but the D5 square is only weaker
with that light Square Bishop
disappearing at that night on D3 could
somehow maneuver itself F2 D1 E3 if
you're looking at the letters on the
board there so Rook D1 is is also a bit
of a start of that but watch out for G6
G6 is coming from turizaga and that
Queen
she might have wandered a little too far
because there's a skewer how do you deal
with that G6 looks very playable I mean
it's a very it'll be a very funny
situation the black queen as well ain't
it when you play that movie but I guess
white has to come back and go F4 maybe
oh it's on the board we're gonna find
out the problem when I noticed it was
that it's not just that the queen is
looking trapped there but even if you
Retreat there's a skewer because the
Rook stands behind her and ultimately
that would be a material win can you
push the F Bond
comes with weaknesses as well suddenly
holes around the white king yeah if the
Black Knight comes back the downside of
Simon points out his Black's Queen looks
pretty awful as well but wow look at
this nice change okay and I love this
idea from Wesley I think this is
actually better than F4 especially when
you're entering time pressure don't open
your own King it just increases chances
of blunders you have a pawn for the
exchange and look at that D6 pawn and
it's that 17th piece once again just 16
seconds for Eduardo trizaga he's up an
exchange for upon that White's Knight
jumping onto that Central Outpost that
uh David you have been pointing out
Knight coming on to D5 this looks like
more than enough compensation for Wesley
yeah
play with white you just improve your
pieces black really having to contort
just to stay alive and this is ugly
chess that Bishop G5 looks like a killer
to I'm not I say killer I mean there's a
lot of play left but the White Knight I
mean you could if you want to keep it
very simple take Black's night off and
that night that white knight is coming
to the most beautiful Square you can
imagine and it's going to come here now
anyway that night look at that you can
never really dislodge that piece and
white has amazing compensation but the
problem is practically when you're
playing these positions what side do you
want even if it's equal you want to have
the side with the easier play and wait
now going for the exchange still still
quite complex now I mean he didn't need
to grab that one immediately yeah it's
interesting decision given given the
compensation yeah look at Eduardo's
decision taking H4 blowing open White's
King I like it I love it I don't think
Wesley should have done this I agree
this loses a bit of control and gives
Eduardo what he wants but he's only got
seven seconds left but look at the white
king the white king I don't care what
the evaluation Bar says it it is weak
the Black Knight can come to F4 The Rook
can come over this is this is dangerous
of Wesley really dangerous yeah there
Comes The Rook G5 the you know this is
this is uh that King is exposed but
she's realistic from Wesley I think it's
uh all turned around now White tonight's
so far offside made that last move with
just one second on the clock G5 was an
idea that Simon you pointed out earlier
it's on the board King's on the Run
gonna take this one this is this is
absolutely amazing the nerves that this
guy has had and every time scrambled
it's game time on the board
he's game time back on the clock he
might be up on the clock if the moves
continue at this rate so tense and now
he's trading off White's active night
for the passive Black Knight White's
King in so much trouble from both sides
of the board Black's Queens can start
jumping the tourism needs to move though
you can see the Panic on his face
creating threats though with every move
called look at that he's got his hand on
his head there he is so stressed out
he's so close in this one he stumbled it
around but can he convert this into a
full point well look at Knight F5 coming
for Wesley too if Wesley finds the right
move here now he's under 10 seconds he
actually has just as many attacking
chances against Immortals King here
that's very slow The Black Queen comes
in this is I practically much better for
black he leans in did he miss that move
I think he's wondering where's the beef
where's the mate but he doesn't have
anything here and Wesley can even take
the D6 Pawn
wow this is Wesley is staying with it oh
there's too much pressure on him
Hannah King he's freezing and he's two
points down now yeah and only one more
check and white smoke is ready to come
back and block ah and the queen is now
coming in
what a move there a subtle Retreat she's
going to enter into C8 and the attack is
on the black king
White's night holding everything
together there they say a knight is a
king's best friend White's night is
beautiful yeah a tourism and you can
just tell Wesley is the much calmer you
know the pressure it's immense and you
can see that Eduardo is
yeah you get the rook in and look at the
turizaga he knows he was so close but
now it is falling apart and that is
the end of the game
Wesley so holds on reminiscent of how he
held on in the scramble versus Fabiano
look at Wesley he reacts what a danced
battle that was at the very end and a
heartbreaking and
foreign
another wild roller coaster and that's
what it is when you play against Eduardo
trizaga with the Sicilian and there we
see Wesley
he is relieved he's relieved and as I
was saying he held on and won a similar
game for those fans who watched
yesterday against Fabio carwana in the
first game in their match very similar
in that it could have gone either way
there for a while but Wesley's nerves
seemed to have arrived here at the AMCs
rapid nabs are still by Wesley
's critical moments David take us
through that big big spot in the game
yeah as Danny said this game could have
gone either way there were a few twists
and turns there Wesley came up with a
great material sacrifice but maybe
grabbing some material back a bit later
on backfired and this was the moment
Eduardo got excited we saw on the camera
he jumped in with his Queen it looks
like he's got some devastating threats
some nasty checks in store but the move
that shocked him was the fact that white
could calmly capture this pawn and
suddenly he panicked iterazaga couldn't
find anything here he gave a check and
this was the moment that the game
Slipped Away instead of playing the very
slow defensive move Rook G6 he should
have continued being consistent
continued attacking pieces and queen
takes porn counter threatening the White
Knight would have kept the game alive
this one would have still been been in
the balance and any result possible
instead he went passive and got
checkmated heartbreak but accuracy from
Wesley so yet again
and now it is a threesaga who is in a
must win a situation going into game two
Wesley so after thrilling roller coaster
takes a game one with the white pieces
Eduardo will start game two with black
and we'll be back with all the aim chess
rapid action in just a few
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
the winner between Wesley and through
zaga will go on to play not back up to
Saturday it's all about getting that
final spot into the aim chess rapid
final to fight it out against Magnus
Carlsen the goat he's waiting he's got
arrested today he will be playing the
grand final today and he tomorrow and he
was dominating in the tournament so far
in the winners final but how did he do
when we put him up to an air things
challenge take a look
so now we're going to try the air things
memory test two years ago in 2021 I
tested magnus's memory by setting up a
bunch of famous positions and seeing
whether he could recognize them this is
the 24th game from Sevilla obviously
now we're going to do the same but with
an added twist we're not even going to
be able to see which pieces are which
every piece will be represented by an
airfix device instead so let's see how
Magnus gets on
first of all I'm thinking like what are
all these pawns on the last rank but if
I'm going to go piece by piece I'm
hoping that this is a king and these are
pawns and that this is the bishop and
hopefully Queen H6 should be mated two
2016 right yes Carlson against karyakin
so this test is called has mine has been
following the world championship the
ding is wide against the Premiership and
here he could have taken the Rook with
the queen invention Queen goes back here
King to D2 green blue
F3 and eventually the king is
running away I think should have found
this thing
is this any more difficult for you uh no
not really the games are too famous
that's the problem this has to be a
Kasparov to Paulo from 99 in RS what
characteristics make you recognize this
position maybe like it's just the
structure on the queen side that's a
queen and this is a queen and he played
Brook T4 CD4 okay fine
Queen C4 oh he takes an F6 yeah he takes
an F6 nice okay
okay I need to know my Classics oh my
God
so this one is one of my happier early
chess chess memories just from the world
youth Championship under 14. I'm playing
Black in the first round against the
future Grandmaster Hammer that's the
king over there checkmates
and this looks like checkers
so few pieces but it's definitely a game
I've seen huh
it's I don't want to give it away but it
you will have that's the clue you will
have seen it
is this from like entertainment maybe
maybe
hmm
oh yeah so there's this one where
oh
no that's not it I'm not sure I'll
actually seen this okay
in that case I apologize
it's from the Queen's Gambit TV show
when Beth plays what's his name towns in
the first her first ever tournament oh
there's this yeah there's okay I can't
remember that but there's this weird
trap yeah and this is a rook and it's
trapped now because there's a nice and
deep foreign
[Music]
impressive and you've got a chance to
win the earthings wave plus device
signed by Magnus Carlsen head over to
Champions chat store Twitter and solve
this puzzle submit your Solutions using
the hashtag chess Champs and you could
win this
add things with plus device that I've
got with me right here and it is signed
by Magnus Carlsen and I just noticed
it's got the queen at the back David is
this one of the I think devices that you
had on the on the challenge yeah I think
it's one of the pieces we played with uh
in those games great price I know the
answer to the puzzle
the contest okay not a lot but you can
have
to the Champions chest or Twitter for
all the details on
right now it was Wesley sauce Queen who
got the job done at the very end in game
one and he's ready he needs a just a
draw to make it into the losers final to
take on Noddy back up to such off
one thing we know that it is going to be
a fight it is going to be fireworks on
the board and Simon you are happy seeing
the English I am yes it was nice to say
in English
um again I have to say Obviously the
opening with the best name in the world
in the best accent much better than the
Dutch the French
um that's about all I can think of at
the moment Scandinavian Scandinavian
Sicilian yeah that's right it's got a
great name and uh we're seeing a more uh
is a lot of fun I would say great city
as well and uh this this is actually
quite a quiet start right David I mean
this is like the ready uh variation of
the English where
um you you basically give a lot of space
away with white but you're trying to get
your Bishops feeling chateaued and um
you're in for a long game uh is that a
good strategy when you need to win yeah
there tend to be two popular strategies
when you're in a must win situation with
whites either you go really direct you
go on the attack remove one maybe choose
a really kind of uh forcing opening line
to test your opponent or you just take a
step back and this is something that
kaspara of Carlson they've all spoken
about actually in crunch moments you've
got to back yourself to play these slow
games and play on the opponent's nerves
and that seems to be what it's like is
doing here it's unfortunate if the
momentum of this event continues the way
it was every time we've had a player in
a Muslim situation
they had black and when they won
enforced Armageddon in this case
iterizaga has white in a Muslim
situation so if momentum is is anything
or at least the vibe of this tournament
he may not be able to get the job done
even though he's already done it before
when he had the black pieces but even if
he's able to get the kind of position
that he got in game one that's his
chances right it's anyone's game then
and that's what he needs to try and
create and with that in mind is this uh
the opening approach that could work
foreign
it could he's done it before he's an
expert in these type of flank openings
so I think he's just going back to
basics what he knows and loves best but
I'm skeptical against someone like
Wesley so I am too and the reason is
because Wesley has faced this type of
approach against hikaranakamura so many
times online and Blitz Wesley already
has a little bit of an advantage as you
can see from the evil bar there it's
because he he's seen this this circus
before right so again he turizaga I
think you made a really great point he's
playing to the psychology of it he's
going to get a position he knows well
calm himself and let the let the game
happen right but but I think Wesley is
also feeling comfy
I would have thought Wesley's very happy
with this I mean it's always nice to get
a space Advantage when you had the black
pieces it's very rare actually when
you've got the black pieces to get more
space than your opponent and you can see
here the real issue that white has in
this in this structure is that black
pawn right in the middle of the board
that black pawn is so annoying for white
it sort of cuts the board in two it
stops white could not coordinating
easily and um okay I mean Eduardo went
for this type of structure so he's
obviously happy to get it but it's it's
not supposed to be scary for black is is
the problem and uh he's gonna have to
hope uh Wesley goes wrong and Wesley's
now supports that pawn in the center
with another aggressive Pusher yeah and
one thing we have to do with all
openings is uh kind of recognize
patterns recognize Pawn structures and
this is what we call a benoni structure
normally that actually arises with
reverse colors uh so it's black choosing
the benoni there but this time it's a
tourizaga who's playing with this Pawn
structure with D3 and C4 and like that's
giving the opponent more space and
problem with the benoni is it does have
this reputation it's I think it
translates to son of sorrow and they do
say even the best benoni
it's an opening that you get tactical
chances right but positionally it's just
supposed to be bad right so the benoni
is baloney yeah so white essentially in
the in the baloney opening is trying to
push pawns on the queen side often you
want to kind of push where you're
stronger beside you must have happened
the majority black meanwhile plays in
the center often playing for this brick
uh with E4 that's why Eduardo has
positioned his Knight on the C2 Square
he wants to support this push while
keeping some pressure on this D4 Pawn
making E4 less likely but here black can
start by clumping down on the queen side
slowing down the process uh on on that
flank also you do have ideas of just
bringing your Bishop out targeting this
weak pawn and all of these things they
do tend to add up I'm very biased here I
love this structure from the black side
so I am curious to see what tourism has
got in mind other than just giving
Wesley kind of kind of positions that
he's not used to with black as Simon
says you rarely get such a promising
position this early
yeah thoughts here predictions I I think
that yeah I think you laid it out really
well you can tell in our in our tone I
guess as chess commentators we're biased
toward the chess in the end and the
chest position is favored for black for
a reason you can see the email but at
the same time again it's it's uh it's a
position that is going to have Dynamics
I guess similar to the Hedgehog Tanya
and that at some point the benoni tends
to explode things like the bishop on G2
becomes open the tactics on the B file
so there's opportunities for your
opponent to go wrong right it's not a
static or symmetrical position and and
that can put that can play to your favor
in a rapid time control where you know
again at some point both players won't
have very much on the clock
it's a good opening to play if you need
to win as well right yeah I mean if you
need to win it's probably the best
opening to play because even if it is a
bit of baloney uh you you get and I love
that side it is it's full of balloon
it is you get tactical chances and you
keep all the pieces on the board and uh
things as Danny said can just burst into
life and Eduardo there after his last
movie is threatening to expand on the
Queen's side so he's got ideas of his
own he wants to push that beep on up the
board and Wesley slowed down it's
already good news for Eduardo if you can
get Wesley to think early on so that
once those critical moments arrive you
don't have that much time to sort of
navigate through the complications but I
think right now fight water it's also so
important to forget the last game what
has just happened it was such an
adrenaline rush for fans for
commentators but for these two players
especially so to just leave that behind
him because I just saw with his um hand
holding his head right now it felt like
he was still thinking about what had
just gone by but he needs to forget that
focus on this and it's the kind of
positions where chances will come uh
chances for both players to go wrong
agreed
there's actually an instructive thing
here if we want to talk about it that I
think the traditional move would be A5
and that's a move we all think about in
these positions to slow down White's
plan as Tanya pointed out before but I
think more modern computer prep wisdom
has actually changed the way the players
look at that expansion I think what
Wesley's considering is actually Bishop
G4 or even H6 but let's play Bishop G4
because that's a common move in the
benoni because often you're actually
happy to get rid of that Knight and if
B4 happens you make some other move like
H6 again these are common moves and if
B5 happens the Knight actually will head
to A5 and what's funny is instead of
trying to block it you let it expand and
there isn't much more to do and there
isn't much more to go and sometimes you
will see black play B6 and relocate and
use the C5 Square they'll use your space
against you and oh my God Wesley push D4
wow okay that's what he was thinking I I
that is not
that is not normally what you're
supposed to do we saw the lines I was
giving where black maintains an edge
Wesley is all in on on something he sees
to take advantage of now which I'm kind
of surprised by this move yeah it feels
like he's well he's got to draw in hand
a draw would suit him and he's just
trying to blow open the position trying
to force the issue but uh yeah that
normally doesn't follow conventional
wisdom where you have to prepare these
types of breaks obviously if you trade a
pawn in the center then Black's Knight
will jump in there's access now to C3
there might be a nasty Fork on the White
Queen and Rook so I'm not sure whether
that will be appealing to a tourism the
other option would be to take on D4 and
what is the idea here it looks like you
might sacrifice a pawn temporarily do
you just move the bishop out the way
maybe to attack this Knight to bring the
bishop out to attack the White Queen
first you take G3 you take G3 yeah for
example jumping out the way with the
bishop yesterday in the fall but the
Knight as well yeah maybe here it's just
the fact that white special should be
very strong yeah maybe just take the
spawn as well and okay we'll trade down
to an end game where White's Bishops
will be very strong but yeah I would say
something he's calculated something
but he had a bit of a head shake he
played E4 and then he it felt like he
wasn't really sure about what he's done
or just sort of going into this tactical
Skirmish when he needs only a draw but
the one thing that I've been noticing
about Wesley this tournament we keep
talking about Wesley's so solid right
but the decisions that he's been taking
have been very uncharacteristic the one
against Fabi not repeating not bailing
out going into this crazy massive
position what we saw in game one today
and then this decision to go E4 when he
has the option to go with the same
developing move does that surprise you
at all completely surprises me and I and
I'll even I'll add further context here
for those who watched on day one he was
up a game in the match versus Notre back
and he kind of beat himself in that
match remember guys he he gave Notre
back chances again we called it very
uncharacteristically Wesley so this
moves remember when he took when he
played C5 and gave the diagonal the
changes so I totally agree with you and
I think we suffer mostly from Magnus
bias itis as commentators maybe hikaru's
second but we also suffer from Wesley
biasitis so I'm trying to justify E4 but
the reality is like that was a bad move
like the computer say was a bad move
like if you look at chess.com events
it's a bad move and it's it's not the
right way for black to keep an advantage
here and I think there's a reason he was
shaking his head
yeah but uh maybe he's not playing for
Advantage here maybe he just figures
that at the very minimum the center will
blow open things will get traded off
still trying to calculate my way through
this and it's her it's for asaga as well
clearly uh surprised by this last move
Simon is this something you would do
would you have built up or do you think
this direct approach is going to pay I
think you have to calculate it I mean
you have to calculate the most forcing
move in the position always because it
can it can change things in your favor
and this is a very typical break that
you play in this structure
um it you know it is a bit impatient
maybe but if it achieves the goal and
that could be multiple exchanges
everywhere you know there could be just
pieces pawns coming off the board then
uh you know that's maybe something that
Wesley's seen that I haven't seen I
don't know if we've seen that he he can
just tell that that after the exchange
it will come to uh a bit of a drawn
position but yeah I mean it's strange it
I I also agree it's not like Wesley to
to play in this way and he normally
plays a bit more patience
um but we'll see I don't know if it
blows open and he gets the drawer then I
guess we'll be like no I knew it was bad
but I was simplifying but I but I agree
with you not like Wesley and
see I still not sure what white should
play here though so it's like we say all
that and it's like what does white
actually do you know who it gets like oh
say and often the top players they do
this right often they know when to not
follow conventional wisdom rather than
slowly build up as kind of is prescribed
here he's just playing the position
itself he doesn't see any reason not to
do it so uh he's kind of yeah backing
his own calculation here he's calculated
the fact that he thinks he can get away
with us and he's also forced into razaga
to burn a lot of time here four minutes
suddenly no more just slow maneuvering
kg nervy chess it's just calculation
battle Yeah we are opponent plays this
move that Wesley just did and you better
think because it is a critical moment
right now for Eduardo and Simon you
mentioned you don't know you wouldn't
know how to respond to this uh situation
not just you I saw feature chat which
said that not sure what are the plans in
this position and David it will be
really cool if you can highlight some of
the ideas and strategies that both
players can have to develop this game
yeah let's jump in and show some right
now it's become very concrete if for
example uh Wesley hadn't blown open the
center with this move then I think as
Danny was mentioning some of the ideas
either you expand on the queen side you
can start building up first bring your
Bishop out maybe reposition your queen
to connect the Rooks and then play for
this Central break but now that Wesley's
gone for it let's investigate uh what to
do here I mean my first instinct and I
think what a tourism is calculating is
whether he can get away with being
greedy let's just show this one more
time I think maybe the downside is we
see the evaluation bar react slightly
maybe the downside is that black can
just move the bishop attack the Knight
and you're forced away and no matter
where you go this Pawn is dropping next
I also liked your Bishop G4 that you
mentioned the first time now that we're
here I think if Knight takes Bishop G4
is also really strong because the queen
doesn't have a lot of options
and then the d-pawn and the Knight are
even more vulnerable when that Bishop
moves so I didn't calculate beyond that
but just proving your point that this
shows why ichirizaga can't take on D4
either Bishop G4 or Bishop C5 body
language expert required right now did
you just see through zaka he's been
thinking for a while and then he leaned
back hand on heads there what's going on
in his mind right now break it down for
acai I might be expert again I love
these segments can we just say that I
love these settings hey how you stay in
body language Mr Williams over here and
my fine tuning of the players is that
Wesley is very relaxed there that little
turn of the head to the right hand side
shows that he's just recalling a bit of
information and they're banging out the
moves on the board so we might have to
go there and you're going to save my
judgment on what's Happening so it looks
like a turizo I found the right line
though he took a lot of time yeah but he
looks like he found the right line
because he's still holding the balance
that C3 Pawn is a is a target
did you read that comment there
for you I'm not sure Simon what's my
body language trust the man with the
beard
what's your body I wanted to sneak into
your cam but they went to the shared one
I I think a body language for uh Eduardo
he's still I mean when you lean forwards
it's a natural way to say you you're
still very excited about the game you're
quite excited about your possibilities
when I'm playing chess if I've got a
good position I'm definitely more over
the board and when my position is a bit
bad I tend to slump back a lot more
um so I think he's I think he's probably
happy happy the way things are going
um the position has changed a lot so we
should probably go there but the White
Knight is now in a good route right
David coming straight straight into the
middle I guess yeah let's talk about
what's changed in the position we saw a
quick few moves there to rizaka did
calculate and let's just do an action
replay he decided to capture this Pawn
in the center and the Black Knight
jumped in and rather than Panic like I
would have done about this night jumping
to C3 he says okay I can trade you off
once you get there and now after 1983 I
think it's just all about the C3 Pawn if
it lives obviously Wesley's doing well
any end game is going to be great for
him there will be tactics to do with
advancing this Pawn later but if it
drops off the board in the next two or
three moves then simply white will have
an extra pawn and great central control
so a key moment for Wesley right now I'm
loving this last night move as you said
Simon on a great circuit you can jump to
the center it also stops the black
Bishop from ever landing on F5 uh to
kind of either hit this Rook or also
support the advance of this black pawn
I'm wondering whether jumping in with
this bishop somewhere
support this Pawn a bit later on is one
idea maybe black just needs to get
developed
but either way big big moment for Wesley
so he needs something now otherwise
strategically White's doing very well
it's going to be all about time in can
Eduardo truzaga get to that C3 Pawn
because that would just mean he ends up
with a position with an extra Pawn so
will it be a big strand to our weakness
and he starts with a move that threatens
to trade pieces Eduardo is perhaps going
to jump in with the Knight is that a
good moment
I like edwardo's position here I again I
know it's I think he played the calm
moves and I guess I'm kind of standing
by what I said I just I didn't like E4
from Wesley I think obviously
simplifying the position look at what
he's done he's offering a queen trade he
maybe wants to make another minor piece
trade maybe Wesley's thinking that even
if he loses that C3 Pawn he has good
drawing chances in the end game we
should remind anyone tuning in Wesley's
up one nil which means a half a point
moves him on to the next round so Wesley
is playing a little bit with house money
that said I still don't like it and I
think he's giving Eduardo the kind of
position you want when you're in a must
win position which is you have a safe
way to keep pushing so I'm I'm um I'm
liking Knight D5 here and I'm liking
Eduardo's chances
yeah likewise I think that this is the
type of position that suits Eduardo as
well it's slightly imbalanced and uh
also he does have a good positional
sense so he knows exactly where to place
his pieces he's debating whether to jump
in with the white knight to D5 or
whether to trade Queens first there we
go and wow we're going straight for that
pawn we said it was the key uh Square
the key piece right now and okay can
black keep that pawn alive that's the
key question for Wesley
yeah strange I mean
I totally agree I mean that pawn is a
weakness isn't it more than a strength
at the moment
um you can't really easily hold on to
that pawn in any way that I can see and
uh maybe you just have to give the pawn
up and try to use your two Bishops but
White's night on E3 is is such an
octopus it controls so many squares with
its tentacles I'm just pretending to be
an octopus here so you kind of know what
I'm talking about and uh you know it's
going into the center to the left to the
right stopping the bishop coming in here
we go are you like are you conducting
what are you pointing at no I'm just
fine I've just been a chess bra there
for a for a moment uh I know they're
over in England on their tour at the
moment so hello to them but um yeah it's
such a strong night and it just looks
like wait wait is doing okay but can
Wesley find a way to neutralize things
and sort of head towards the draw
there's nothing simple here is there
there's no easy way to do that yeah
that's frustrating when you just need a
draw when it's a bit too much in your
mind when you want to just force the
issue that's I think the reason behind
Wesley playing this uh eform if we've
been talking about and right now he'll
be realizing there's no way to just
trade everything off he's going to go
down a pawn and he has to
dig deep now to find compensation first
of all but also to make it a bit messy
so that white sex report doesn't
actually count and yeah why tonight if
it does jump into the center it's going
to be one-way traffic you've got to be
really careful here Wesley to stem the
momentum and what a fairy tale be if we
get an Armageddon game and we'd love it
you know and something happens so so he
is giving up the pawn now yeah and I
think this is probably the wise choice
try to get counter play somewhere else
you do have two Bishops you you know
your dark Square Bishop is incredibly
strong we should mention that it's a
really good piece Black start Square
Bishop lots of range it could go to well
we should mentioned Wesley shaking his
head there I mean he's just objectively
not thrilled about about what happened
here although he can't see the Evo bar
we can I guess now that we've I've been
critical of it I'll say like decent
drawing chances here right and all he
needs is the half points so as long as
he can let go of his frustration he's
probably still in a decent match spot um
even though Eduardo you got to be like
well
I got a chance right at least I have a
chance here to send the storm again yeah
successful Eduardo and the fact that
he's got a position with no risk where
he's the only one who can really win but
yeah objectively as you said Simon I
think the key piece is black start Squad
Bishop unchallenged beautiful piece
there and gives great compensation often
that's modern chess as well Danny
mentioned it with the Advent of alpha
zero and all these neural networks
Bishop has squares activity often
pushing the Rooks pawns that tends to be
great compensation so yeah it's going to
be hard for white to somehow turn that
three versus two Pawn Advantage he has
on the queen side into something more
tangible it might be forming while
trading off White's best piece logical I
suppose another thing black can head
towards is opposite called a bishop
position uh if one pair of knights gets
exchanged then he's able to swap his
light Square Bishop for the Knight
there's going to be many theoretical
draws there where there's there's
nothing that can be done and there we
see our brain in a cup
I was wondering if that image could come
on the screen and go without you
mentioning it
I had an interim there with myself and I
lost no no chance I have to comment on
on the the flying brain in a cup image
which is uh and if you if the fans
actually get their hands on this trophy
they'll be flying to Toronto for the
season and final that's right that's
maybe that's why it has wings and maybe
that's why it's flying is because it's
it's going to get you on a plane to the
live final
eight big brains waiting in Toronto for
big brains Magnus Magnus already there
Hikaru no they're back already there
Wesley so I mean it's a guy you want to
see there he is the reigning Global
Champion right he and Magnus were the
only two because Magnus was the reigning
tour Champion Wesley was the rating
chess.com Global Champion the only ones
who were seated into our first event but
Magnus punched his ticket and Wesley
hasn't so and her car was there actually
because he is the speed shot champagne
that's right that's right so
and we see uh some trades have happened
now black does have the bishop power in
compensation for that extra Pawn that
Eduardo is enough and again the question
is is it enough to win it's really nice
you're playing this position for two
results uh as Eduardo but is this is
this going to be enough David
this is the tricky thing without the
evaluation bar I would be super excited
for white uh I just don't see any
immediate way for black to neutralize
this position and to either get the pawn
back or trade off or the Rooks go for
opposite color Bishops like you say
Simon and uh also the clock times
roughly level I think that will be a uh
kind of source for of relief for Eduardo
compared to the last game but then again
we see the eval bar and we think okay it
should be level but let's talk about it
because I think regardless of us blaming
the evil eval bar I think there's a
reason for it okay I love king of Fate I
was going to suggest either that or G6
because what I want to point out here
David if we bring up the analysis board
is squares matter high level computers
continue to teach us things that we
always knew which is look at who owns
the only really open and effective file
right if that Knight on F3 ever moves
there's the D2 Square for The Rook
right we talk about who owns the pawn
tension white can never really take A4
without creating all kinds of problems
like opening the brook and weakening C4
and you can't challenge the D file
because Black's Brook is there so this
is
right the dark Square Bishop holds every
square if you ever want to advance your
three on two majority and by the way as
I said the Knight can't move because of
D2 and if the Knight can't move that
Bishop on G2 is not playing so again
like as you break down the specifics of
the position there's reasons why this is
equal like black has a phenomenal sense
of of control and phenomenal
compensation yeah and that's why these
top players especially the Strategic
players like Wesley so Magnus they're so
good even when they're pulling down they
know what to play for and yeah I would
love to just leap over the White Knight
with this bishop on D5 but illegal
unfortunately you mentioned that I mean
I was just we have to coordinate the
white pieces here right and it's very
hard to find squares them I was
wondering if you could leap in uh with
the Knight into the center of the board
and if Black's Brook comes in then you
go Rook D3 uh something like this I just
I just you have to get those pieces
working as white another problem that I
guess Eduardo's got in this position is
it's just harder for him to play right
Black's position is very easy to play
and White's position I mean I'm just
trying to find moves that that you you
can actually do here and it's not easy
so that's that's why I was trying to
activate the night like that open the
bishop up but
um if you get one more move plant the
bishop on this beautiful Square on D5
then suddenly you start hitting
weaknesses as well and uh yeah just this
resource I was skeptical because of Rook
D2 but I like I love it Rook D3 and the
whole idea is if uh black takes a pawn
then there might be some uh infiltration
on the back rank yeah I mean if that
doesn't work it's terrible idea but you
know if it does work then somehow then I
don't know but maybe it doesn't quite
well you've got to do something now
because Tanya's uh 17th piece is is
yelling at us saying hey
it's time to make a move does it
surprise you that Eduardo went for this
position with the queen trade in a must
win situation do you think he rushed
with that it's a really good question in
hindsight because maybe he like Wesley
evaluated the compensation correctly
maybe Eduardo underestimated the
compensation right because all he's done
since the Queens have left the board is
think yeah and he's realizing well crap
like what do I do here right what am I
going to do and I almost like Simon's
idea of 95 just for the sake of
acknowledging that he's in a must-win
situation go 95 maybe Rook D3 maybe
bishop D5 next to go after F7 right
because otherwise you take another two
minutes off the clock for both players
and you really like Wesley's chances
there's a must answer question in front
of us why does Dani not wear the pawn
costume for this is it coming up for the
final you know doing doing commentary in
the pawn costume has never been done
it's never been done I like that request
um
by the way that thing is so heavy
and you can't travel with it it like
literally so it takes like we have to
box it up and ship it a month in advance
it's not something you throw on the
plane in your carry-on it's not possible
it's as big as it looks did you see when
David dressed up as was it Tinky Winky
I'm not I'm not exactly sure
versus Tinky Winky all right we've got
H3 and G4 Lisa was a plan
yeah all pawns on light squares uh a bit
slow I think your tourizago just spent
what was it three four minutes there and
came up with a blank he just decided
okay actually I can't see a way to
improve my pieces without allowing
blacks pieces in so he decides to push
pawns control some squares he stopped
the black light squared Bishop from
coming out to some active posts but
other than that it's a bit mysterious
feels like he's again just throwing the
move back uh kind of delaying the
tension again this will come down to a
bit of a Time scramble uh it always
seems to but yeah he's just hoping that
black content proved in the meantime
okay how about plans for Wesley so we
talked about what white can try nothing
was too convincing there how does Wesley
keep the compensation going
I wonder if you can just play tickle
little Bishop C5 action I'm gonna Rook
C3 Bishop back to B4 I I don't know I
mean but he has to do much because white
has done exactly what with H3 and G4
yeah oh wow Rook A5 now he's saying I'm
gonna be a little more aggressive
West advocated cool maybe he's going to
start pushing on the king side White's
giving him some targets maybe H5
something like that switch Focus Black's
got only long range pieces the Rooks and
Bishops your wizard Harry good old Harry
coming out the back I don't know what I
said that was but
anyway I like this move because also I
think Wesley's saying okay well White's
not doing anything so I don't need to do
anything myself except to improve those
pieces which are really like not
activated and okay so now now we maybe
see is there an idea yet that white is
generated I still can't see an idea from
White and in this position we have an
exchange yeah he was just again it's
tickling every move
I think uh I think Harry's a real boy or
a real wizard I'm confusing Pinocchio
and and Lord of the Rings apparently
it's a real move in this position you've
got the two Bishops you want to open up
and try and create as many weaknesses as
you can in your opponent's spawn
structure will Wesley try to push for
more and he does it how are idiot fun he
does it we called it I mean David called
it he said we're K5 we I I spied with my
little eye a little Harry Pawn on H7
yeah it's just beautiful these top
players they make it look so natural
just kind of switching all Focus from
Queen sidely to kingside in the space of
two moves but yeah this is uh why
they're so good and it is it to rizaka
ready this is going to cause him to
think again there's no easy decisions
here for white either you take this H1
off the board and wreck your own Pawn
structure flax Rook allowing it as well
to swing over or you find something
creative and tactical nothing obvious at
all for white time has get ticking down
as well I mean uh he's gonna get to that
situation where he's going to be under a
minute uh very shortly and as as good as
he plays quickly it's it's going to be a
struggle because you need to you don't
have an easy position to play I think
that's the real problem that white has
here Black's position is much easier to
play White's playing kind of awkward
looking moves and okay moves his Rook to
defend that pawn but again there's not
really any Act activity that white can
get at the moment of his pieces I just
want to point out that was some Top
Class chess that we just saw by Wesley
right he pushes he does this Rook lift
on one side of the board and at first
you're like where is that Rook headed
but the idea is on the other side of the
board the king side he goes for this
push with the H Pawn creating an
additional weakness for white now always
got to watch out the Rook is tied down
to defend that light squared Pawn uh on
G4 and Wesley's Rooks are getting active
the Bishops are active how does Eduardo
survive this with 40 seconds it's an
amazing Point Tanya in fact what Wesley
did with this Rook idea in H5 was
develop the bishop on C8 because as you
point out the Rook on e4 is now tied to
G4 so that Bishop on C8 is playing a
major part in this position now and I I
really think that's a great point every
one of Wesley's pieces are to be
preferred really
I mean The Rook on e4 I guess optically
looks okay but actually he's kind of a
serving a donkey's task there holding
down that pawn so what do we think of
this though The Rook was a bit uh Clumsy
on the E4 now he switched across maybe
some ideas of his own I like this from a
tourism striking maybe G5 there is a pin
remember the black king is not entirely
uh comfortable either
yeah both players just playing great
chess you've got to place them both 34
seconds though I do fear and okay there
is a Target first of all on F2 yeah not
easy to defend that one and if the
Knight jumps over Black's other Rook
will come into the game on the second
rank so he does
no sorry this is analysis
you're showing your ideas I just lost my
my blood pressure just dropped I need a
snack he did amazing time plays the best
movie covering this book sorry that
really scared us I was in your boat
Johnny although I will say we should be
ready for that moment because Wesley has
kind of lulled us to sleep with this
calm tenacious defense
he's really put himself in a great spot
it Martyrs down to 25 seconds don't be
surprised if Edward does blunder because
he's running out of time I wish I had
controlled a computer I'd have so much
fun with you guys oh my gosh after that
reaction I'd be I'd be dropping pieces
every other every other minute just to
get you get you going there
um do it on purpose I promise favorite
crafty and well this this seems like
white white it doesn't exchange help
here I mean uh maybe not because the
white porn is also very weak
it's gonna be so hard to win this right
15 seconds if you could somehow put that
white G Pawn back on G3 maybe you have
some good winning chances but yeah
weaknesses everywhere and Rooks off the
board assignment you might have been a
prophet here I do foresee a position
where the Rooks disappear opposite color
Bishops Could Happen uh later on could
be yeah I love when you say I do foresee
you say that again I do 4C that just
sounds so prophetic it just sounds
powerful pathetic
I do foresee I do force it a future a
future where I'm talking about Harry
Potter too much I think it's contagious
it's now they were travel to Middle
Earth all right here we go we're uh we
got Bishop G4 I've scored Bishops are on
the agenda and Wesley so we're losing
our Focus but this guy Eduardo six
seconds he could now go for that
opposite card Bishop thing but there's
no need to probably take that Knight yet
but I mean that would be really
excellent drawing chance but this is
much better just use the two Bishops
Wesley so it's playing great I mean
three seconds but Wesley so is all over
this I think they're both playing very
well to be fair because white could have
easily have gone wrong with the pressure
he's under here but he's still finding
moves that are keeping in the game this
is a great move centralize the night to
the middle uh you do have the extra Pawn
so you know Wesley can go wrong and you
can convert that pawn still still game
on David you think Wesley should have
taken a three when he had the chance I
think maybe yeah I was a good Bishop was
an opportunity he didn't take it but not
anymore and there's no way that Eduardo
can repeat this position he has to find
another Square for The Rook what is this
he already did because now it's obstacle
Bishops and Wes he's in control and
there is no other Square for the rookie
had to go for the second award
repetition
well we really I didn't even realize it
but yeah that repetition was forced oh
Wesley wants more he's pointing out that
Rook D3 is the best move he's gonna get
a draw oh he has to keep attacking the
bishop like you say Danny that would
have been the third time the position
repeated so iterizagos had to choose
something different but but now in the
trade The Rook won't be guarding F2
which is why that was such a subtly nice
move by Wesley Rook D2 Rook G4 Bishop C5
he gains a Tempo yeah
I think that would most likely lead to a
draw but can Wesley forced the issue
okay this is what we're going for he's
gonna do it
that white Beacon is going to drop as
well
hey yeah it's it's
King E7 first likely or or even King F7
you're not really worried about the
check anymore I mean why it's got the
extra Pawn but it's pretty Irrelevant in
this position I mean uh for those of you
at home I mean the opposite card Bishops
most drawest reputation I love the
statement by spaski I've said it before
but I'm everybody got divorced he got
divorced and he said about his wife and
him he said we're just like Bishops on
opposite colored squares we were never
connected and just going past each other
all the time that's great it was a great
great saying and uh
um I mean white still has that pawn but
he's got to keep his Rook on the board
the Brooks come off they can just shake
hands so uh he's doing the best he can
um but Wesley's played so well up to
this point that's a good news for
advisor that he's placing all his pieces
on light squares the king will move
forward to defend that Bishop so that
the Rook can be free but it's not going
to be enough he's being against Chastity
so solid gives a check right now uh
frees up the bishop
but this one looks like it will end in a
draw which is four seconds on the clock
this could be about those last few
seconds in the aim chest rapid
one second left yeah that's the
brinkmanship there is impressive I know
another player he used to do that all
the time
at this point 51 is really strong
because Here Comes Rook G1 big track and
King E5 is next and the white king is
actually entering a little bit of a
meeting net okay he plays E6 with Tempo
but uh coming that black king yeah he's
gonna play King E5 and when the king
comes up he'll be pushed to the edge of
the board so again it should be a draw
I'm just I'm pointing out that Wesley is
uh being ruthless here yeah Black's
Bishop has just been perfect the whole
game and okay there he goes he kicks the
white Bishop away blacks Bishop just
controls the advance of White's pawns
it's cuts across the whole board and you
know I think the best white can hope for
is to trade off those Rooks at this
point I would be scared of getting
checkmated uh that white king looks so
lonely there vulnerable to some checks
you have to keep them on though don't
you I mean a loss is the same as a draw
so you have to keep the Rooks on the
board and hope that something turns out
there and this is the end of it there's
nothing that yeah Eduardo can do to
avoid Rook H1 check
he'll play King H2 oh no he won't it'll
be a draw right here yeah and there we
have it Wesley so beats Eduardo through
Saga goes on to the losers final to meet
not the back up to satro when Wesley
they're relieved with his performance
Eduardo 3 Saga what a fantastic Ronnie
had at the M chess rapid but it's this
man right now who's got reasons to be
proud of uh a crazy game in game one and
then keeping it solid and in control in
round two and this was a fairy tale
story but it does come to an end for
Eduardo Saga what a match that was
Wesley saw one step closer to that Grand
Final against Magnus Carlson he will be
facing not a back up to satra of next a
strategic fight this one David yeah
strategic battle and both players played
extremely well we've got to command
iterizaga on a great fight but
ultimately Wesley so just too solid and
it was this position where we would
actually thought that objectively Wesley
had gone wrong as black but finding
compensation for the porn that is doomed
on C3 he came up with a really
instructive maneuver developing these
pieces especially this Rook on A8
without needing to move it A5 was the
key and this was really instructive
after A4 black actually had fantastic
compensation look at the power of this
dark Squad Bishop which actually sat
there pretty much until the end of the
game in the end iterazaga kept his Pawn
but wasn't able to win
fantastic and game there a play there by
Wesley so let's take a look at our
bracket and we are reaching the Finish
Line at the aim chess rapid bestly so
advances in the loser semi-final
notification has been waiting for the
winner of this match to play in the
losers final and that is coming up next
it's a match that we've seen before and
it happened on day one of the game chess
rapid it was not a bag who took that win
is this going to be a grudge match for
Wesley I think it is a grudge match and
I think he's going to get his revenge if
if you were watching Wesley was up by a
game let it get away from him but
sometimes you need to start slow in
order to find your form and Wesley has
gotten better with every single match
since and I think he's hungry he's
hungry and he wants a chance at Magnus
and he wants a chance to punch his
ticket to Toronto
and uh the one player who had an amazing
run put up an amazing fight but he's now
knocked out joining us Eduardo trizaga
Eduardo how are you
[Music]
of course I'm disappointed because I I
want to win but of course was a tough
match against
Wesleyan I think in the first thing I
have some chances in the time travel but
he he managed to play well with 10
seconds and I miss one Queen B3 I think
at
the end when I play Queen C3 and then
okay so I have some tricks maybe he's
better but it's slightly better not too
much and with 10 seconds everything can
happen right but okay he he controls his
nerves more than me and he he deserves
uh some nice words there Eduardo you
know your games are always so much fun
to commentate on and so entertaining for
the chest fans do you enjoy these kind
of crazy tactics and playing in these
time scrambles
yeah yeah like a lot I uh when I was
jumped I like 10 11 years old I I used
to usually to play one minute but bullet
like crazy but then like uh five six
years ago I left and I just played okay
some title Tuesday or this kind of
tournaments like in Rapid tournaments
but not not bullet but I just still have
some
[Music]
and I like to of course it's not easy to
change our mind when we was playing like
15 minutes and then we have to play with
10 seconds
30 or 40 moves more right but uh yeah
yeah I like I really like to play this
kind of games crazy games
Eduardo you uh you earned so many fans
uh with this performance even started
with beating para magsulu and everything
you did this week
I'm an even bigger fan now I was already
a fan of the chess I'm an even bigger
fan getting to know you as a person let
me ask you have you ever considered
streaming and do you want help with that
so that fans can see you more because I
can help you with that have you ever
thought about that thank you so much
yeah but I think
I want to start to stream in our or do
anything like a more than than play
tournaments is uh maybe in a few years
right now I and after this I wanna play
a lot and I wanna
trying harder
now to try to to play again in division
one and
to to get better of course in in chess
but thanks for the for the offer and if
in one moment I I wanna stream I will
tell you just give me a jingle give me a
jingle but seriously Eduardo thank you
so much and what an event yeah
thank you
all the fans for the support
thanks a lot again for the opportunity
before before you go you won so many
hearts tell us what are you playing next
where can everyone follow you
and that's quick I will play I don't
know 24th of July again the plane I will
try to do better again and and then I
will play the workout
so that's a busy a month ahead of you we
wish you all the best and we look
forward to seeing you in the next
championship store event thanks guys bye
bye
what a performance what a run there by
Eduardo turizaga starting from the
planes knocking out love on our own and
on the way and what a fight he had
winning so many odds an amazing story
there it is the end of the road for him
and we've got a big Winners losers final
coming up before we head into the
winners bracket tomorrow and we will be
back with all the action as NADA back
and Wesley are getting ready for their
big matchup on the other side of this
break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
basically it's a tool for improving your
chess game it gives you tailored lessons
for different phases of the game and it
seems like a very useful tool so again
better than players around your ratings
it looks like you get a really nice
overview over over your games and what
you need to focus on and what you are
good good enough at to have all my
weaknesses black and white on paper is
devastating and interesting and fun at
the same time the middle games are a
really rough and aimchester said it to
me again so and that is definitely the
most popular move there today I actually
learned
if you're a beginner beginner it will
pick out kind of the basic things you
need to improve on and also Advanced
plays is very detailed at getting
straight in working out if you're
opening is working your tactics and
giving you some personalized lessons so
it's pretty broad pretty much everyone
and aim chest was great at finding out
that most that nearly everyone we had
their endings were actually very bad so
they need to work on yeah work on that
area of the game to be honest I think
aim chess can help everyone
um it's helped me especially approving
the opening realized my strengths and
weakness is there and in the end game
where actually I thought I was very good
but it pointed out areas that I could
work on if you want to improve on
anything from start and opening to end
games any level can do aim tests I
suppose
[Music]
improve faster with aim chess your
personalized coach and you can get your
first month free with code CCT at
go.chess.com aim chess so head over for
your aim chess analytics and it's
forever faster with Puma our cool
lifestyle Partners making our players
and commentators look so good all the
time and here's what happened when
Magnus Carlsen and Christian pulisic had
a little chess and football crossover
foreign
[Music]
Chester I sort of two main strategies
there are people who just play the same
openings every single time they're
basically just saying yeah
um I trust and Trust in my prep I trust
in my strategies that there are others
who try and adjust it more and frankly
like I like both as a part of football
as well there's some prep you know
potentially what your opponent could do
what kind of your plan going into the
game how you want to attack how you want
to defend how you want to press football
games chess games they're just being
decided by by really avoidable errors
thank you
[Music]
a big part of football I think is like
taking care of your body doing the right
amount of training but also not killing
yourself and you know tiring yourself
out especially during this end part of
the season it's all about recovery and
and just making sure that uh your body
feels as close to 100 once the games
come around I certainly kind of matched
that if
sleep while the tuition is the
tournament goes goes well because you
have less you know worries and such
I never really had Heroes there are a
lot of players in both fields that I
admire immensely but one of my favorite
players growing up was Luis Vigo I
obviously love watching the you know
kind of the Ronaldo
messy kind of rivalry unfold and they've
been so fun to watch for so long I don't
know a ton about the Chess World but
I've definitely just followed magnus's
path he's definitely
top of the list
[Music]
football I mean I'm definitely an
attacking player who just likes to be
creative and likes to put Defenders on
their back foot and just kind of keep
them guessing that's the kind of the
style I like I like to be very
aggressive very very direct towards goal
so that's definitely my style in
football it's easy I'm terrible uh just
I would say
pretty Universal but definitely leaning
towards positional rather than
than tactical play the games that I play
it's just about not making that critical
error I guess for me chess is also quite
simple
[Music]
yeah having your own Puma shoot is
pretty special so I'm definitely proud
of it and uh yeah I'm excited for fans
to be able to pick these up the shoes
are really stylish I love the look and
I'm excited for the future and for
people to to experience them Magnus here
are your CT Puma boots here are my
signature shoes I'm gonna wear them out
of here yeah
good stuff
Magnus and Christian there with their
Puma shoes and looking very good there
Magnus mentioned he's been terrible at
football what would be his football
rating David
about 800 no I'm joking Magnus is really
good he's being modest there and I saw
those two have a kick about afterwards I
was actually the one interviewing and uh
yeah Magnus was able to keep up in some
of the you know the kipiopies the
football drills they had so I think both
were impressed with the other side's
Specialties there yeah School
he's been a hero too A whole generation
of chess players one of them now his
biggest rival and he will be in action
not a backup do satro of comes back for
the losers final against Wesley saw
Simon what are you expecting with this
one
a great match uh as simple as that I
mean they have fought off as we know
earlier on but Wesley was not in good
form and I think Danny mentioned he's
going to be looking for Revenge now so
this will be a really high quality
exciting match and I think we're going
to get everything we want
yeah and here we see the aim chest
starts between these two as they aim to
fight off against uh Magnus tomorrow and
you know we see impressive numbers maybe
the biggest differences come in
Advantage capitalization not to back
extremely good there with the Killer
Instinct overall his accuracy is pretty
close to Wesley as well and we've talked
about how Wesley's one of the most
accurate players out there uh impressive
numbers Danny yeah it is super
impressive and uh the the information
behind the stats too one interesting
point I want to point out is that
sometimes right now these stats are
favoring the lower rated player in
Advantage capitalization over the higher
rate there's a reason for that these are
run on their most recent hundred rapid
games you know who Wesley so is playing
more often in his last 100 rapid games
players like Magnus Carlson players like
five minutes so I'm just pointing out a
little bit of the game behind the stats
because we see Chad talking about it it
doesn't take anything away from the
stats I think it's fascinating but it
points out Notre Beck is getting good
points because he's beating the people
he's supposed to be and that doesn't
take anything away from 93 but also
doesn't mean that Wesley doesn't convert
his advantages he might just get less of
them and the advantages may not be as
big so again I look at those numbers and
say very very close matchup on paper
there's a reason the last one went to
Armageddon and we're in for a treat
and in the very first event of the
Champions Chester season 23 in the air
things Masters Wesley did make it to the
winners
who took that match and eliminated
Wesley so this is his second shot at
getting to that Winner's final for not a
backup destruct from Magnus Carlson
they're already into Toronto they've
made it they punched that ticket is
Wesley the one who's feeling the
pressure right now I think that's
another reason why I'm I'm picking him
not just because it's hard to beat
someone twice and the last one went to
Armageddon Wesley's also a stronger
player still at this point in
notorbeck's career I I do believe that
but I think Wesley's motivation is there
and he knows that he needs to punch his
ticket directly by winning an event
because I don't know that his Grand Prix
points are going to get him there
and the players are ready to go for this
big losers final to play against Magnus
Carlsen in the aim chess rapid Grand
Final and there we have them on camera
what do you think naughty back's been up
to today has he been following the
action preparing what did he get up to I
think a mix of those a bit of chilling
bit of prepping uh maybe he had us on in
the background some of the players do
we've seen Fabi uh tune in from time to
time but yeah he would have had half an
eye maybe on the Wesley game but he
would have known big match either way
and he'll be ready there we go E4 to
start this one off
Simon your thoughts on the body language
there well back to the expert as always
and they're both quite cagey their hands
are hiding something so maybe hiding
their preparation but you see that
Wesley's hand is a little bit lower and
there you go the first surprise Wesley
head in his hands a little laugh he's
clearly shocked there and it's one nil
with a little smile let's talk about why
let's talk about why if anyone missed
Notre back's demolishing of levonaroni
and shame on you you should check it out
but he played a dubious opening that
notabeck himself said remember guys that
he's like look that opening is
objectively lost for white no meaning
what he did but he crushed Iranian now
he's playing another opening that is
objectively dubious we weren't wrong in
terms of how we evaluated it but it's
full of traps and full of tricks and
Wesley's like you saw the reaction he's
like oh crap here we go like what is
this kid got in store with some sort of
magical preparation
we talked about the English opening the
Dutch defense the French this is the
Portuguese opening and you nearly never
hear about it because it's so rare it's
then
[Laughter]
he's laughing he can't believe this move
it's usually played on the third move
but this time on the second move is this
second Warfare by uh not the back I mean
this is like the drunken rule Lopez
isn't it it's like you've played it on
the wrong move I've got my knight out
yeah what have I done it's the kind of
thing you know ten point rule Lopez how
many times have you played the drunken
Roy Lopez um I've never played Rawl
Lopez actually which is weird but I've
done the other thing
very well over the course of my life uh
but yeah it's it's a stranger because
it's basically saying to Black okay
attack me I mean again if if a pupil I
don't really teach anymore but if a
pupil of mine had played this movie I'd
be like you can't play Move like this
he's laughing wow you can't keep it
together she's like I'm surprised and
Wesley also I think you can see him on
camera because Wesley's like oh like
you're laughing I'm laughing but
wrestling is also burning his clock
right now and it's going to be pretty
funny Wesley develops tonight not a bad
steaks out the king side night and we
have a royal Lopez a Spanish but Westies
burnt two minutes on the clock it's very
weird because yeah I mean I you're
asking black to attack your Bishop
aren't you I mean like you move a piece
into your opponent's half of the board
the first thing generally your opponent
does is kick that piece away but this
time I I don't know David the Portuguese
variation I mean it just looks weird to
me but I love it and I love the way that
he's got Wesley thinking on move too how
often do you get Wesley thinking on mood
two and he might still be able to play
the Kings Gambit I'd love to see that F4
go I'm going to get excited if that F4
moves oh come on okay by the way Wesley
did play the objectively best move
according to chess.com's opening
Explorer C6 scores 64 for weight for
black so C6 scores 64 for black so he
did play the best move although now
after Bishop A4 there's a number of
moves here for black including Knight F6
including D6 and then we'll see it
probably scored so highly for black
because no strong white players play
this over that's probably fair but uh
I've got to say I think this is the only
the second time in my entire life I've
seen the Portuguese opening first of all
but also it's the first time in three
years of commentating on the Champions
chess tour that I've seen both players
laughing like that yeah so early in the
game sometimes at the end of the game
okay there was that Bond Cloud incident
between Magnus and the Hikaru but wow
Bishop B5 and Wesley's still smiling uh
Tanya talking about burning minutes he's
uh down to 11 already and still making
faces like that one D5 lashing out okay
that's shakes his head raises his
eyebrows makes a move he's definitely
not part of the prep for Wesley but now
we know what nautiback was up to this
morning
oh by the way because if we want to show
that he takes D5 normally it would would
be frowned upon to bring your queen out
into the center but in this case after
he takes D5 Queen takes D5 if you attack
the queen you've left something at home
with this whole Portuguese variation
right if Knight C3 Queen takes G2 and
was Simon's shirt would say
it would say just resign my friends just
resign just resign okay your computer's
in the way it is yeah okay there we go
do it again do it again no one saw that
it's okay we go just resigned great
great and good good that's another wait
Simon get ready to show it again there's
another trap in the position this Pawn
is attacked if you block with your
knight oh I love it oh whoops oh Shack
and now you regret developing your
Bishop so early this bishop falls off
next there's some tricky things there
aren't they just resign there he goes
again yeah get it in there and um I mean
it's it's I like what Wesley's done
right because uh he you could be like
okay my opponent has played a weird line
I'm a little bit scared about their
preparation I'm going to do a sideline
but he's not no I'm going to play the
most critical moves your your Portuguese
is just rubbish what you're doing you
can't do this against me I'm Wesley the
great so I'm gonna test you out by
playing good moves right so I like it I
like it it's challenging right
challenging yeah so I'm not sure either
of these players played the Portuguese
or speak Portuguese at this point just
judge you by the clock times clearly the
home cooking's gone a bit wrong wow and
I'm saw that Wesley's responded with the
most critical moves on the board
attacking the bishop playing for the
center not about going into a think
after that is that surprising wait why
is he thinking now no but I I agree with
what you said and and tonya's follow-up
because I I was gonna highlight the same
thing that when you face an opening like
this from your opponent it's easy to get
nervous and then try to think of bailing
out right Wesley laughed yes he was
nervous and then Notre back left but you
know what he did in the end he tried to
play what objectively would seem to be
the most principal thing to do he's like
it makes sense that I should play C6 and
I should go for the center because
that's how I would punish a bishop who's
left the G2 Pawn behind in those lines
we were showing so I'm applauding Wesley
regardless of the fact that he had to
use three and a half minutes to get
there I think he took the most
principled approach and I'm I'm guessing
that it might pay off given how we're
seeing Notre back react and I've just
seen I was thinking Knight F3 would be
interesting that was another way to lose
a piece there but okay I mean we see
probably the most logical move drawing
out the black queen and uh it's like a
it's like a Zoop top Scandinavian maybe
as well I mean uh you know still I don't
know I don't know what's going on after
Knight F3 here they that that could oh
yes I do know what's going on you've
already showed me that
I've already I've already lost that
piece already so oh Queen F3 that's a
bit that's a bit sad yeah that that move
isn't it it's a little bit that's loving
this by the way and they say that I love
the comments that are coming and both
players hilariously forget about their
clock and and lose on time
um so people are going to start trying
the Portuguese now shout out to John
Bartholomew this is the new Scandinavian
clearly yeah and good for black right
now and yeah Queen trade isn't going to
give white the advantage but he needed
to do it there were just too many traps
too many tricks in the position and we
see Noddy back frown for the first time
in this game because his home cooking
doesn't taste as good as he was hoping
F3 sounds like my cooking
don't worry
we have that in common I think
black can do a number of things here
um you know principled moves Knight F6
get developed rather even developing the
advice where Bishop would work the dark
Square Bishop don't do that because that
would hang the Queen the ball is pinned
um that's actually pretty funny to show
like if you play Bishop C5 just for fun
assistant phone has been I don't know
why that cracks me up it's been a long
week apparently that correct that's a
chest joke for you
yeah I can safely say we won't see
Bishop C5 on the board but yeah it feels
like Wesley is going to allow the trade
of Queens you don't really want to step
her away you lose a lot of time that's
why kind of bringing Queens out so early
is frowned upon if you start running
away too much you lose a lot of Tempe
but I was gonna say he's going to do it
on his own terms and he says no okay you
uh not Bishop C5 sorry that was my
analysis he said he does trade-off and
okay A bit surprising to me this Pawn
now attacked if you step it forward you
might well run into some problems this
Pawn would be attacked there might be
ideas against the F7 Pawn his whole idea
was to play this move a sneaky move and
maybe he's going after this white Bishop
not the best piece in the world and yeah
roughly balanced would we say still life
left despite the absence of Queens Vice
pretty well developed here right I mean
uh you you could it's the pawn in the
middle strong or weak that that that's
something I'm wondering I mean it takes
some space but it could also be a Target
the rook's gonna give it a little probe
and uh you know the the pawn is going to
come up or should we say nibble should
we get the rabbit out again give it a
little nibble and uh nibble nibble uh
but yeah I mean it's it's it looks
fairly even I I guess right
a lot of life left though I quite like
just the fact that it is relatively
imbalanced despite the Queens being off
this early so queenless middle game with
all the minor pieces on the board
everything to play for but that long
think by not a back uh going into this
uh position with the queen trades what
are the chances that he had this
position in his prep
I think less now I mean just given given
that he's used time I mean remember what
happened against the bonaroni and right
he was he was playing on on the on the
board winning playing on the clock and
winning I think he I think he
objectively knows this type of position
was possible right when you play a
dubious opening but
but I don't think he's thrilled or was
spending a lot of time hoping for this
position yeah it's interesting because
Wesley's third move D5 it's pretty much
the whole idea of the Portuguese opening
is to stop that movement he just played
the move that shouldn't work that white
is trying to fight against and uh yeah
it feels like that surprised after
Satora so maybe just a kind of a lapse
in preparation there which is rare from
these top players but occasionally they
forget to check
certain moves and yeah it feels like
just judging by the use of time now he's
definitely not ready in this position
Wesley stepping forward I've got to say
slightly surprising it looks like this
Pawn could be pinned if White's Rook
just slides I want to show that because
that's I think the really tech key point
is that if rookie won
yes the pawn is pinned but you don't try
to defend it you played Bishop E7
because I'm coming back to your idea
David wow if you take it
this is actually similar to the last
game we saw Wesley play right I mean uh
even if even if white can hold on to the
pawn which he might not be able to you
get the two Bishops you probably can't
hold hold on to it anyway here right
um White's Rook like squares I like the
fourth rank I really love the way
Wesley's playing this because uh you
know you could be scared and you could
be like okay just I'm just going to
equalize but he's actually trying to
really punish nordie Beck and play the
most critical moves and it's a great
lesson for anyone out there who wants to
improve
um always try to play the most critical
moves I mean it's just a very simple
little rule the most challenging moves
for your opponent because you will get
better even if they backfire
occasionally it's a great way to beat
better players and improve as improve
your chest so and that's what Wesley's
doing here playing a risky yet very
challenging move and we've been seeing
that narrative by Wesley paying concrete
chess and sort of just destabilizing the
position and going in for these
complications and it's paying off I'm
still thinking about that second move by
notabeck taking his Bishop out to B5 and
if it was part of the biggest strategy
of his opening plan which it clearly was
in some ways it reminds me of what
Magnus has been doing early on in the
open playing these offbeat openings 186
just trying out these different things
is this not about just saying I don't
want to get Wesley into an opening
battle just get a position and play it
out
I think so yeah
um but I also think he was in
predominant known the reason Notre by
played Bishop B5 I think he was I think
he was hoping to catch Wesley maybe in a
trap like he did against LeBron I think
he was you know look I mean similar to
what we talked about the other day about
how top players are willing to take on
positions that aren't even that great as
long as they know them because we know
the computers have told us you can play
anything now so I think it's worth the
gamble it's worth the gamble maybe he
wins a miniature and if he doesn't is he
objectively in a great position here is
white no but a position is fine I mean
even with how Wesley's played so I I
think he played it for the gamble not
even for the end game or throwing myself
I think he wanted a chance for a
miniature and now he's got less time
than Wesley on the clock
already tricks we've seen it already
with these tactics as Danny pointed out
and yeah actually if you hadn't told me
or hadn't shown me that aronian game a
few days ago I would have said this was
just a mind fight he just wanted to play
the Spanish openings the drunken the
drunken Savannah drunk in Spanish but
yeah it's just it's a gamble but we
can't say it's failed yet it just hasn't
kind of reaped uh the rewards that he
was hoping for
body language expert coming in uh Psy we
saw that little Shake of head by Wesley
oh what's he thinking is he is he mad at
not a back for uh for this opening
choice I think I think you can see from
his uh leaning in language and he's
staring at the screen that he's now
recovered from the initial shock
um as any good uh person would do and
he's looking off to the side there he's
thinking yeah that was a bit cheeky of
naughty Baker I'm now back on top are
you leaning back showing satisfaction in
his position and relaxation he's taking
a deep breath there just to calm himself
and he realizes that he is actually now
in a pretty stable and good position now
naughty Beck on the other hand
say that like if anyone tuned into the
show for the first time right as Tanya
said let's bring in the body language
expert and then and then Simon just
delivered on that they're literally here
thinking wait is he the body language
expert like those are the chess experts
and that's why you're here
body language expert forget about the
chess I will uh pull out all the body
language you deliver it thank you
flagging is what we say in England and
uh okay rookie once played so uh so this
is where uh Wesley has this very
interesting review you mentioned Danny
of just Bishop B7 yeah we don't know yet
but I'm yeah
um it looks quite scary for white this
position because Knight C5 is actually a
pretty big move and if you can somehow
maintain that pawn in the middle White's
going to struggle to develop so it
whites in a lot more danger of getting
in trouble in this position than black
is I mean even if black loses that pawn
he's going to get compensation always so
a bit scary you know this position for
for weight I feel I'm watching chat here
David and people want to know why F5
doesn't work here for Black Label we
should okay
let's jump in and uh there are various
tempting moves here for black this Pawn
is attacked and of course it's pinned so
it cannot move uh the black king behind
it if you defend this Pawn if you back
it up immediately with your own Pawn
then I think white is simply yeah okay
yeah and uh now the extra pressure on
this Pawn White's pieces have opened up
you haven't necessarily gained anything
as black you've only weakened yourself
with F5 and yes you can continue
Defending Your pinned Pawn in the center
but eventually it will most likely Fall
Off for example Knight to C3 and this
Pawn is now more of a weakness than it
is is a strength which in the game we
think it is so with a clever move such
as Bishop to E7 that was pointed out by
Danny you can kind of indirectly defend
this Pawn due to this double attack one
of the most typical tactics in chess and
this looks like it pays off for black
another move you could consider is a
dual purpose move kind of defending the
pawn with your knight and attacking the
white Bishop I think this is kind of the
kind of the way up right now due to play
Knight C5 or do you just save it up your
sleeve for later it's funny that black
has no fret after Knight C5 it's quite
weird right because you you take the
bishop you lose a pawn it's it's
peculiar right so for example yeah
double attack again
all sorts of tricks in this opening and
it's only move what eight now crazy
stuff very peculiar we'll only move
eight and both players have used half
their time exactly yes and that's a lot
of time and the action is just getting
started on this one and this is clearly
new territory for not a Beck as well
even though he was the one to come up
with the move that shocked us all in the
commentary uh Studio here
and uh Wesley now reaching the seven
minute Mark deciding how does he defend
the pawn or leave it hanging with all
these tactics that you're pointing out
what's the moves that you think he's
going to go for here will he develop
that Bishop is that in Wesley Style
the longer he thinks the more I'm
inclined to say he's going to go for
Danny's move to block this pin with
Black's dark Square Bishop but yeah I
mean if it was a Blitz game you kind of
automatically Instinct wise just play
Knight C5 it looks natural you attack a
piece you defend your Pawn but yeah the
fact that he's spent nearly three
minutes now means he's looking for
something clever the top players only
pause when there's something uh kind of
difficult that they're considering
taking their time on every single move
there and while they do that we'll wait
for Wesley uh to respond to this threat
on the board we've also got our eyes and
ears
division two updates Cathy what happened
in the winners final Tanya no one wants
to go home but as Simon says they
already play from home so they're
playing actually a lot of a lot of very
nice games but they are just ending in a
draw in fact Dennis lastovic and Sam
Savin they played one of the games for
150 moves I thought they would never end
that game but they ended that game and
they started another they are now in the
fourth game so far they the result is
equal and as I mentioned there they're
very likely we're going to see
Armageddon in the division two and
another result we have Mark penis kicked
out garakamski and now he's facing a
convenient and they also have a three
drawers so far and we still don't know
who is the leader in the second division
wow that's so cool and specially 150
moves between danlos and Sam savian if
that did go down to the wire Katie who
is there a favorite there but no they
are equally good they both have their
good games and in the end it turns out
to be a draw so looking forward to the
Armageddon
let's hope we've got the Army getting
fun in the division in division two as
well and you can catch it all on chess
dojo's Channel or chess.com events
how much would it mean for these
youngsters Danny to get that 10K and to
book their spot in division one
10K is a lot of money already
um and um I think division one is is
what everyone wants right I mean Notre
Beck punched his ticket not that we're
surprised he's a former World rapid
Champion as as Magnus reminded me but
one of the best players in the world in
Rising but I mean I mean did we think
for sure he would be there no right and
he won the chess kid cup so I think that
anyone has a chance as long as they make
it to division one and Bobby bunched his
ticket to division winning division two
as well that's right that's right and so
division two is maybe the fastest route
avoid the play-in right which is a bit
of a Gamble and we know it can be super
tough especially if you look at the last
plan where it felt like every single
player in the world was there so I mean
it's uh definitely a big deal to win
division two it was Magnus who said that
the plans for this Champions Chasta
season they're a lot of fun to watch but
not so much fun to play in yeah they're
they're an absolute
a nightmare adrenaline vest to try to
play in the plan um but uh anyway if you
get to division one it's worth it
absolutely so there is a lot of on the
line we'll keep checking in with Kathy
for updates on the big matchups in the
other two divisions and now we've got
moves on this one it is the direction
that we were expecting David yes the
direction we were predicting here and
Danny you'll move on the board Bishop B7
clever stuff and notibeck he's had to
put his Knight in the center a bit of an
awkward Square White's Bishop still
hanging uh in the air there on A4 it
feels like somehow this is turning in
Black's favor but again the clock time
might be decisive if I'm surprised to
see Wesley think now it looks like he's
got a very natural move just bringing
out his undeveloped Knight and getting
castled
really confused as to what abjatorov is
doing next to be honest it feels to me
like I'm just a tour of coming in fresh
with this nice opening idea he's come up
against Wesley who's Just In the Zone
after his much earlier today it feels
like Wesley's built up this head of
steam
what do you think I I would choose black
here Simon Danny thoughts yeah 100 I
mean uh I I think uh Black's got a very
nice position I mean uh he's gonna take
that Bishop the light Square Bishop at
any moment and that will give him the
bishop pair the poor and E4 is maybe the
only thing which is of a little concern
I mean uh if you if you don't lose that
pawn you can have uh more space it's
kind of uh like a fawn in in White's
position is stopping white from
developing and uh okay an interesting
move here just developing the bishop
maybe getting ready to Castle stopping
any tricks on C6 but it just looks like
Black's got a much easier position to
play how does white develop those Queen
side pieces Danny I mean you know the
Rook on A1 the bishop on C1 uh how did
you get them into the game it's not easy
I really like that move pointing out
that the Knight on C3 is stuck regarding
the A4 Bishop right you can't take the
E4 Pawn because you lose the bishop and
so let me just accelerate my development
while you're stuck well you're stuck fix
seeing these awkward pieces that you
started Notre back with the Portuguese
right I'm gonna I'm gonna develop and
get castled and
and maybe I'll play Knight F6 next to
the guard the poem but I don't need to
and I love if you've got to Rook to d8
the D4 Knight is vulnerable right so I
know that eval bar creeped up a little
bit for white I'm not sure what the best
move is here for the engine but I really
like Bishop D7
um don't like that he took so much time
to do it if I'm if I'm in Wesley's
corner but
but yeah I'm with you this is looking
good for black maybe white just has to
play a move like Bishop B3 to kind of
force your hand and then if you take at
least I open the a file that might be
the idea okay yeah like that might be
the thing that prevents
castles long so perhaps Bishop B3 will
be what we see from Notre back yeah it
feels like you have to drop your Bishop
back sooner or later it's just uh
hanging on A4 in lots of variations it's
a tactical weakness so I like it Danny
um still an issue as Simon mentioned
with this bishop and this Rook behind it
for example if black just develops
protects this Pawn but that's an issue
for later just keep your Bishop nice and
safe maybe the idea will be at some
point to just get rid of this Thorn as
you said Simon in order to eventually
play D3 and unleash this piece but yeah
step by step he's got to move quickly
both players have just been yeah so
ponderous at this point
10 10 moves and and 10 moves for 10
minutes not usually a recipe for Rapid
absolutely and it all comes down to the
second move and now this move on the
board what a shocker that pushing that
pawn pushing that night out so a little
aggressive chest here uh buy nodded back
I'm just thinking this is such a
different Dynamic from what we had in
the previous match Eduardo versus Wesley
absolutely crazy chaotic chess and this
just feels like a slow strategic fight
who does that favor these kind of
positions well it I think it I think it
would favor Wesley although I will admit
after B4 I think we might be about to
heat up because that pawn is now
vulnerable
and if black castles long there's
tactics on the d49 so yeah you're right
John it's been slow they've been taking
their time and strategically trying to
navigate this this odd opening from uh
Notre back but it might be about to get
spicy well if it's about to get spicy
and it's about to heat up then let's
hope that Wesley's got good air quality
going on because he's going to need all
of that this position will explode
meanwhile this is the puzzle that you
have to answer for a chance to win this
Athens device uh you can go on uh
Champions chess store Twitter and it's
signed by Magnus this will be coming
your way if you get the answer right and
it's also the same as things device that
was used by Magnus and David in their
air things challenge so go ahead go on
Twitter and try and solve the puzzle how
good was Magnus uh with the ethics
challenge David he was too good for me
that's that's for sure not just in the
game that we played against each other
when we were maneuvering pieces not
knowing what they were essentially
blindfold chess but also in those
puzzles I thought I would confuse him uh
he didn't know which pieces were which
as we see on that puzzle in front of us
as well for the viewers but yeah he
solved them very quickly I'm still
thinking what's going on in that puzzle
there what is it I mean yeah sorry I was
looking at the board and that was a
puzzle as well because it was a massive
moment where I think black could have
grabbed the button I was looking at the
same tactics Simon I I think black could
have played C5 yeah I think why did he
not do that I think that was the whole
point of this B6 move was to play C5
attack two Knights win a piece but I
think Wesley took a judgment call and
assumed that white would get just too
much uh activity for that David I mean
but there was a big moment there big big
moment big moment and let's rewind back
to that it was B6 on the board I was
about to praise it for being a really
sneaky clever move and I think Abdul
sotorov just bluffed he played Rook
takes porn allowing the win of a piece
now C5 as you guys say would attack uh
this Knight and this night
simultaneously and you can't save them
both not do back here for sure had to
sacrifice a piece and I think this was
his idea so now it's three pawns for a
piece so technically fine on material
but maybe it was just the fact that this
Pawn is rolling the bishop is coming to
put pressure on this pinned piece all of
these things scared Wesley however
objectively he would have had the
advantage so he was bluffed and he
didn't take that uh take up that
challenge instead he castled but simply
just down a piece now and after Bishop
B2 the same tactic does not work this
time because after C5 I think you can
simply take this pawn and after the
Knight is captured suddenly a double
attack hitting this bishop and hitting
this bishop that's been the name of the
game so far all of these double doubled
attacks in these openings and I know
that was deep Advantage I know there was
deep analysis but I think you nailed it
as far as why we also just saw Wesley
kind of give a little bit of he went
like he missed something right and I'm
wondering if this is what he missed
maybe he castled quickly because he
thought C5 was possible next and Notre
Beck doubles down on the bluff and now
shows that Bishop B2 is possible and
just looking at how Wesley responded and
by the way he's now about to get under
90 seconds
and another bag has an extra Pawn
yeah I think Wesley let that slip
yeah I mean he's played this very
aggressive move there five David as well
just to attack that Rook but um white
has the extra Pawn white white has now
developed his pieces which he hadn't
done before and Black's behind
development so it's certainly taken a
turn in naughty Beck's favor definitely
it's just that key moment and Wesley
didn't have enough time that's why we
were being slightly uh kind of
questioning or critical of the players
spending so much time investing it
earlier they needed it just that moment
when things finally did explode we talk
about that a lot right time management
and Rapid shows because if you haven't
blundered yet you probably haven't
reached the critical position yet and so
you need your time for later I I really
think that that whole that whole
position where C5 was missed and we saw
Wesley's response may end up being what
we're talking about and you hope if
you're Wesley's sake you don't lose this
game you find some way to hold but this
is um now he's just down upon and time
management is such a tightrope to work
on because you don't know exactly where
you should burn the clock and what
moment you should be thinking how do you
make those fast moves uh automatic
decisions are easy to take but but
otherwise you just end up spending those
minutes and they're gone before you
realize it and I think especially for
these formats for Rapid a world champion
Emmanuel Alaska his advice if you find
it a good move look for a better one
should not be followed
sometimes it's like if you find it good
enough move hurry up and play it yeah if
you find a move player 100 find them and
play it I think that rule is really
overrated so it's like when you find a
good move try to find a better one I
never follow that one as soon as I see
it can move I'm just like thank you I'm
just saying thanks man my my position
does I'm playing it I don't care if it's
a better move you know that's good
enough for me you know so and that's in
Long play classical chess as well so
yeah I don't know do you follow that
rule David uh no I'm on I'm on board
with you Simon unless I have two hours
on my clock and can I sit there and
enjoy a soak up the moment I think
that's a new quote we need it in books
we need you Simon Williams specialty
that wasn't if you find a good move
thank you just just yeah I'm just happy
and uh meanwhile White's Retreats and
black is now threatening maybe some
tactics but he does decide to try and
put some pressure on this white knight
in the middle still awkward we should
mention the two nights especially here
for white yeah but have porn up them
should be a way to coordinate here but
but look at the clock oh gosh for both
of them flag time as Chad is saying
right now it's sticking low and big
decisions are coming up not a backup the
satro of upper Pawn Wesley with the
bishop pair is that enough compensation
the more I'm looking at the more I'm
liking Wesley's practical chances here
right it was misplayed but look at what
it's taken notorbeck to recover from
grabbing that pawn and going back right
I mean again I know the email Bar says
why it's okay but the more I look at it
this is what do you do with that Knight
on A4 if you bring it back you lose the
night yeah this is this is getting scary
there's a reason Notre Beck just crossed
the minute line yeah it's deja vu
remember in the previous game against
uturizer Wesley was also a pawn down but
he also had the bishop pair there and
dynamic chances and he worked that one
pretty well
Simon do you think the Pawn's going to
decide or would you take black here I
mean they're moving so slow are they I
mean I I think it's going to come down
as Tanya says that that extra piece
there yeah which is the clock and we see
C4 I mean I I feel that white should be
doing very well here but it's such a
tricky position there's tactics what
about C5 now that's clearly the critical
move if C5 doesn't work here then what
does Wesley do you know Wesley's just in
trouble because white will play C5 black
has to try something like this I think
C5 has to be played in nordic's idea was
Knight to B5 right now you protect
exactly in fact it's on the board yeah
they protect the Knights by getting in
each other's way
where we see a bunch of Trades here we
could see for example these Bishops
disappear okay first we see another uh
capture and this Pawn is loose so Wesley
can grab his Pawn back he has grabbed
his Pawn back still this white knight is
sidelined yes the black king is slightly
vulnerable to some checks now but maybe
it's not enough we see the evaluation
bar bang in the middle it's going to be
a time scramble and not about that
shaking his head I think he's got too
many threats going on the d-pawn is
hanging your knight is at the side of
the board and it can get very tricky for
him he's uh at the 30 second Mark is not
about feeling the pressure in this
position
it's got to be and his nerves his nerves
and some we didn't talk about this as
much because Magnus Carlson's dominance
on the board was the focus but I feel
like notorbeck's nerves got to him a
little bit yesterday off the board in
his games versus Magnus and I wonder I
wonder if he'll keep his cool here in
these critical scrambles versus Wesley
20 seconds
I mean uh you know it's getting very
very short on time now I mean if he
takes the bishop black just develops
um I guess quite easily with the Knight
and he can block a check on the seventh
Frank and there's no Advantage there at
all
um so but how many seconds
[Music]
oh what's going on he's just trying to
play against Black's development he
doesn't want to trade on Black's term
allowing that night to jump into place
so that's uh that's a good idea there by
not a bag but he just burnt too much of
his clock yeah in five seconds three
seconds he's gonna be stuck here for a
long time remember he lost on time
versus Magnus in game two yesterday yes
it got away from him but he actually
lost on time so notrepec needs to stay
up on the clock okay trades and it's
level material yet again after all of
that drama but Black's pieces are coming
out
here we go whose piece is a better place
whose Pawn structure is better white has
some real loose pawns on the queen side
that could come back to haunt him later
but first activating the night this one
feels like it's delicately poised I
don't know which way it's going to go so
anything could happen here big tension
Notre back is uh he's playing a lot of
online shares so as Wesley this is the
scramble with the waiting for it I think
he's gonna play most part of this game
now with just one second on the clock
and that just means that the chances to
make a big mistake are super high for
nodded back agreed I do slightly prefer
his position I mean uh even though I
know the bar says is equal just having
this little bit more extra space is now
it's quite nice and the white King has a
very natural way into the game you know
it can float in this is a nice maneuver
though by Wesley Wesley's found a great
Square for his knight uh you can put
that in front of the white Rook on C5
and maybe there's a better Square as
well okay even better yeah where's these
Inn
they like Flynn what's the idea Rook
c6496 there's a meeting net yeah he
wants to go for mate oh wow yeah Danny
that's huge maybe the path now is narrow
for black you have to attack this white
Rook with the Black Knight otherwise
white comes in with his Knight and mates
as you said I don't think Wesley side
it's gonna be even 10 seconds oh okay
that's a move that says he saw it and he
backs up in Panic it's a piece he's a
pawn up now but his pieces are very
passive and the black king is in some
danger here right it's kind of Trapped
in the cage the White Knight can try to
move around now yeah it is it's a pawn
it is a porn acting the Black Rock he
does it but it's a mistake oh it's
suddenly he's dropping me because H4 and
A4 now at this point you might lose too
many pawns even if you do win the night
wow wait the second one Wesley you can
take one with check there we go oh no
rookie four oh it's falling apart he
reacts he missed it how did he moved
Rook h8 he thought blacks Rook was going
back to D4 to defend the Black Knight oh
my God that's just honestly that's a
mistake of Youth you got to call it what
it is you just can't pre-move in these
scenarios
now it's a hopeless position just uh
about to be three pawns down yeah it's
it's over it's this is an easy working
game and it's a win with the black
pieces as well which is uh that's huge
this is massive massive yep Magnus
Carlson one with the black pieces
against both Fabian neuterbeck if Wesley
starts with a woman with black these are
hard situations to overcome
wow and that's three extra pawns for
Wesley so he's also up on the clock and
not the back there he knows that this is
all over but it's a good idea for him to
continue not just to fight it out but
also to just calm down the nerves for
that must win game again the nerves got
him that was why but first time we know
you've got to get your laptop out of the
way if you're gonna do that sorry
for the producers here man and are we
doing the drinking game
[Music]
not a bag does just resign and with that
win obesity so it takes the lead in the
match what a fight this was and now
another back in a must win final game
off the rapid disappointed there it
started with a bang but it turned around
for him and Wesley keeping it solid and
striking when the opportunity comes to
him he got the job done David he got the
job done it wasn't smooth but he reacted
very well to an opening surprise now
Wesley and it was here that he clinched
the win after a really topsy-turvy game
white has sacrificed a pawn and nodabek
lost the thread in time pressure by
playing Knight to C4 instead he could
have played a move such as Rook h8
forcing the BlackRock to go passive or
he could have pushed Harry the H Pawn
for Glory but instead Knight C4 and this
is where it fell apart Black's Rook
attacked this Knight he jumped forward
another Pawn fell with check but this
was the Fatal moment he pre-moved he
assumed the black Rook would go back to
D4 defending this Knight and so he
wanted to bring his Rook to h8 instead
however clever moved by Wesley so
attacking the White Knight and the Fatal
pre-move Rook to h8 dropping that night
losing a whole move and of course this
end game was hopeless Wesley takes the
win
so fantastic Nick and nerves of Steel
which in this losers final gets him the
win in round one for the second time
today he takes the lead in his matches
now nordeback Abdul sotrov has to win on
demand and he's got the black pieces
against Wesley so solid what will happen
we will find out on the other side of
the break don't go anywhere foreign
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things air things Masters chessable
Masters chess kit cup and now aim chest
rapid they all lead to one thing the
Champions chess tour finale the finale
will be played between December 9th and
16th in Toronto Canada
top 8 players from the season will
compete to be crowned the 2023 champion
three spots are already taken and the
remaining five will be decided in the
upcoming tour events so follow us to see
who will join Magnus Carlsen in Canada
in December
mark your calendar is December 1916 is
when the Champions chest Star season
playoffs and finals will happen five
hundred thousand dollars on the line and
that's the big aim for all these players
who are fighting against each other and
what a fight we're getting and was also
an extremely fun fight when are very
young daddy Ranch played against
Christian pulisic's spot take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome everybody to intility Arena here
on Oslo Norway we're about to play the
Christian pulisic bot that's right we're
officially announcing that one of the
biggest soccer stars one of the biggest
football stars in the world depending on
whether you call it football or soccer
is now a bot on chess.com we're super
excited to have this partnership with
him and I'm going to play chess against
the bot I think I get to be the first
one to ever do it so let's jump in and
start the game I'm gonna play E4 and
Christian Pops in the corner he says
I've played a lot of E4 games over the
last few days I'm ready all right I love
it I have to watch out for the fact that
my bee Pawn is hanging from the queen
that's a little spicy and if I Castle
he's got Knight F2 what is going on how
good is Christian's bot supposed to be
there are tactics I need to be aware of
over here like the fact that my king
could be wide open and I am taking that
very seriously I think I'm winning
oh wait either my Rook is hanging
Christian is on the attack okay look out
this is fascinating I'm still winning
just barely but his bot is or am I
winning I don't even know I don't want
to lose to Christian's spot
um I don't actually see the wind there
wait looks like we're going into extra
time the pressure's on
off the crossbar so close to Checkmate
yeah
we're going for the attack came to G4
was necessary he didn't play it I've got
King G3 he's on the uh he's on the edge
of the field insert soccer reference I
don't oh my queen to A6 I thought my
Rook was on a B6 I just lost the game
I just lost the game
oh my God
oh my God what is wrong with me I'm
gonna lose the Christian pulis it just
by I feel like we need to like you know
edit the video to make sure that I win
this is hilarious
oh he blundered the pawn I still have a
chance
oh my gosh at least I'm not going to
lose any more to the Christian pulisic
bot
I should be able to draw but this game
is probably going to go forever nope end
in a draw
I mean I feel like that was the poetic
what does he say that fun game looks
like we should play again you're right
we should play again rematch Christian
because we drew
he says I've trained a lot for this game
mentally and physically lots of sleep
tons of practice I uh I am so shocked by
what happened there that I have to
redeem myself
I keep wondering I keep wondering oh my
gosh wake up Dan he's gonna give Chuck
I'll take take and play Knight in but
then he has Bishop
H6 why is Christian pools such as bot so
good
here we go that deserves that that
deserves some defense that's right now
we're gonna take and shake and bake and
this time I will not blunder my queen
I'll move away from Chuck mate we'll get
that Queen we're gonna come over here
and clean up
I am not going to stalemate you
and I am the first human being on the
planet to beat the Christian pool of
such bot it feels good it feels good to
win one and a half out of two games
especially when you're a pathetic
International master who needs to do
things like that to feel good about
himself you know anyway this is actually
pretty awesome the Christian pool of
such bot is live on chess.com you can
play it go check it out play the bot and
then come visit me in my new office I'll
be here
can you do better than uh Donnie wrench
against Christian pulisic has bought you
can go play against him right now on
go.chess.com
proud of it
I I don't think I can possibly be proud
of what I did there hanging Queen H6
like what I mean it was hot outside how
did
this guy
did you not see that there was so many
people I got nervous you know no but
seriously it was hot and I just like I
wasn't even thinking I gave up my queen
so I also even though I was the first
human to win I was also the first human
to draw in a very pathetic manner wow
well Danny you did win the best of two
but right now the big question is who
will win this best of two as the players
are getting ready and not a back up to
satrobe has his task cut with the black
pieces he's got to give it his all go
all in throw the kitchen sink if that's
what it takes at Wesley so he's in a
must-win situation Simon can he do this
he can yeah I mean he's he's got lots of
uh exciting openings up his sleeve he
generally plays very aggressively anyway
he just needs to get the right kind of
position I think he'll go Sicilian I
think he's got to got to try to go for a
double-edged opening I mean we saw
Fabiano go for the modern which is one
G6 in a must win scenario
um he's having a long think isn't he
what do we reckon Sicilian or uh
something else here it's the sill for
the kill yeah he's gotta try something
he's still for the kill he has to be
super careful against Wesley though why
is he not made a first move I think he's
thinking I was going to say is because
he has to be super careful and if you
play E5 you know Wesley cell's got the
Berlin draw in his pocket he's got like
10 of them actually so you got to be
careful he'll play one okay here comes
the so we'll see what he does on Bishop
B5
is a sideline King right the kid loves
it right he loves oh Wesley plays a
scotch That's my boy that's my boy go
for it it's a good opening Danny it's a
good opening
that's that's my opening That's my boy
what's your chest ball course number
four blue you're my boy yeah the good
thing about this as well is that a lot
of the variations for example uh if
black brings this Knight out you can
just bring your night out too just be
super solid you don't have to take that
many risks as white the scotch does have
a very aggressive reputation but there
are ways to play it safely and
neuterbeck goes for a sideline he gives
a check it looks like this loses a whole
move the bishop now forced back but
white has now taken up the C3 square
with a pawn rather than uh the ideal
Square for the Knight interesting yeah
mind games at this early stage
unlike so Wesley thought a whole bunch
before he played E4 we kind of missed
that because we were coming with the bot
video then Notre picks not a ton these
guys were deep in the meta game of like
I don't want to give my opponent a force
draw line and then he went for E5 you
think you got to get a Berlin Try by
Wesley but there must be something that
the top players know that we haven't
gotten the memo yet on as far as Black's
ability to avoid that that Berlin draw I
don't know what it was going to be on
Bishop B5
but now we have a scotch yeah a scotch
and uh now dropping back with his Bishop
this is still well known this position
and the F5 one of the main moves
um I think as far off has had this from
the white side and various other strong
players but uh yeah once pieces
disappear from the board the dark
squared Bishop's about to disappear now
Wesley he's going for that marxy bind
that we talked about yeah earlier
White's still solid played this position
many times as white and uh wait go ahead
sorry now go on just saying there's a
basic but big threat on the board Danny
but take it away but the G7 Pawn yeah
hanging hanging with Chuck it's an
important one to be aware of and so
black actually can play G6 black can
also take on on E3 voluntarily but the
main idea is that with that Knight
coming behind the e-pawn White's gonna
try to get C4 and then the other Knight
to C3 as soon as possible
um and uh White actually has a choice of
fee and keto Wing we've seen two kinds
of Roxy binds the fiancado G3 Bishop G2
and we've seen Bishop D3 so there's a
choice but uh it depends a little bit on
what black does yeah just to show some
of your ideas that Danny for example if
he does kick the knights uh Trader
Bishops followed by white dropping back
and yeah one little two more moves you
play C4 you bring your knight to C3 and
white is very happy it's gonna be hard
to break that one down what's funny
about these positions is that often
often black
you can play Knight F6 but often black
will also go to E7 depending on the
position and try to play for F5 at some
point it just depends on on the type of
idea that uh that they want so black is
thinking about whether probably G6 or
Bishop takes E3 here yeah and I actually
have a horror story from this position
and a nightmare a bad memory uh back in
2000 what was it now 2007 I was playing
in the world under 18 Championship I
needed to win with black to win the
tournament a draw wouldn't have been
enough and I played this line as black
my opponent did exactly what Danny's
recommending there and
and uh he basically did that he just
shut down the game he put his Pawn on C4
Knight on C3 I'll eventually lashed out
with F5 and black wasn't ready and we
could see this happen here I mean it's
uh I mean Black's got to generate
something I'm
surprised not about going for this line
I was I was just about to ask for the
analysis board to show you why this is
actually not considered as effective as
Knight G2 E7 because White's gonna play
F3 here
and after castles which is the main move
white plays C4 right away and shuts down
the studio with D5 and these positions
are considered the ideal ones widest
sort of shooting for in this line with
Knight F5 so I'm actually now neuterbeck
is also someone who's played the scotch
in his career as white look we're
getting this line by the way F3 and I
expect YC to play C4 so Notre back must
also understand some of the move orders
but
um anyway objectively or at least back
when I was a chess player which you know
I don't know what I am now Knight G to
E7 was considered the approach for black
to get this F5 idea as David talked
about I I was just wondering hey Danny I
I guess you're completely right but I
mean if is black Sunny chance to play F5
it's like a line in the English opening
which uh I know Sheriff had quite a lot
and if black can go Knight H5 and F5 is
that is that maybe what naughty bet is
going for to try and get some activity
the white king is still in the middle of
the board
um you know you've got a great grip on
the center if five more moves go by then
I think white will no way can wait lose
this position five moo more moves
without any action happen white White's
just going to be going through to face
Magnus I think black has to has to try
something right I mean I'd be looking at
trying Knight H5 and F5 I mean I just
without these moves I'd be very unhappy
and I was just uh you know I don't know
straight away or if I Castle first but
usually something like this too or
something is met with this
um just so you can play Queen of two and
and on Queen H4 jacket so it's not a bad
idea of Simon also it's not even just F5
not H5 is a thematic idea here if you
can get like
if you can again it doesn't work as the
white Knight's coming to D5 but if you
can get like Knight H5 and a knight on
F4 and like a Pawn on G5 and you can
grip the dark squares that's another way
to do it but one of the fun things I
always liked about these positions is
white hasn't even committed where
they're castling yet and as someone who
probably favored attacking positions
more than he should have a lot like mine
partner right here
um Queen D2 and castles long is also on
the agenda in some of these positions
and then push them baby so I you can
tell I'm biased
um like Tanya was in the Hedgehog I like
these positions for white and I'm
genuinely surprised that Notre Beck
would play Knight F6 guys because
remember he has to win this is a tough
position for black to win I'm I'm
surprised by this but it's move 11 down
he's just getting started and at least
it's sort of uh offbeat sort of a
position which can which does have the
potential to get exciting once these
breaks like F5 do arrive when you're
playing Black when you're playing
against Wesley it's hard to get
something out of the opening I agree and
I and I know what you're saying you
don't want me to put a nail in the
coffin yet I understand what you're
doing as a co-commentator I'm with you
but objectively like you do have to
create Dynamic positions and this is a
maroxy bind that is that is tough to
fight back on and he didn't even play
the lines with F5 so I'm actually
fascinated to see what notoric does here
because I believe in him and I believe
he played the scotch so I think he
understands some things so I'm
fascinated to see him I'm with you on
the rooting I'm rooting for it but I'm
skeptical he has to get that deep dark
Forest yeah I mean maybe he can put the
Knight on C5 as the other idea I mean
just looking at the chest sort of things
but you're right I mean I I think he's
got to break out though right I mean I I
don't think he can just sit in this
position he's got to try a pawn Break
um otherwise White's got a lovely grip
with a Roxy bind and we saw that where's
he's already won a very nice game in
this in the same setup with a pawns on
C4 and E4 against Eduardo uh he just uh
yeah knew exactly what to do there
yeah Wesley will be thrilled just the
outcome of this opening and uh Simon you
mentioned if five moves go by and
nothing happens then White's out of any
danger it's already been two or three
moves yeah I think I think black has
this I so again like Tonya if it wasn't
for the match situation I would be more
fine with it right because like yeah you
can play these slow ideas you can try to
grip the dark squares you know white has
both Queen D2 or G3 here like there's
and you can Castle short but but I just
feel like again I'm just looking at the
type of position it's a bind you know
what I'm saying and like this is not
what I would go for I do like Knight H5
because we're gonna go for F5 at some
point but yeah Wesley is a
he's cooking here
for he calm that G3 keeping his King
flexible where will Wesley for this King
I think that's a big question if this
was a must-win situation for white then
of course he'd go coincide yeah and uh
objectively maybe he should go Queen
side as well but he's just keeping his
options open dropping his Knight back
very surprised by that losing time two
times be gone but it counts for
something right when you provoke upon
move in your opponent's Camp pawn moves
can't pawns can't go backwards there are
always weaknesses that are created and
maybe right now it's not so clear but
later on these light squares around
white king they could count for
something that's true and um I I think
the big the big question black has to
face in these in these structures is so
why will either play Queen D2 at some
point and maybe a rook comes to the
center but at some point on a white
knight we'll go to D5 and and then you
have to you have to figure out how
you're going to deal with that tension
right if you're gonna run away with the
Knight I actually like this plan for
Notre back bringing the Knight to C5
which justifies that A5 Pawn right and
then you kind of want to move the other
night back from C6 and at some point
play C6 and kick White's Pony out right
you want to move that other night we can
just draw an arrow with the pawn so this
is kind of how you maintain the tension
and you're you turn it into a bit of a a
bit of a maneuvering battle because you
don't really want to trade on D5 if you
trade on D5 with either Knight like not
only do the pieces get off the board but
white space advantage and the grip just
gets even stronger yeah he's coming
around for this night nice idea there
how do we think Wesley meanwhile is
gonna set up maybe a night landing on D5
as you say Danny maybe just kind of
super flexible just bringing his Rook
across will he push pawns again we
mentioned that he does it immediately
well uh we mentioned in a similar
structure that this could backfire
suddenly some loose Pawns in the center
we'll see maybe this horn is a bit weak
yeah it's interesting we shouldn't write
him off yet I agree with you Tanya still
very tense
it's not the type of position that we
usually associate with winning chances
but still a lot of pieces left on the
board yeah
I like it I'm going to say that not a
back with the black must pieces must win
situation I think he's got reasons to be
pleased with this opening outcome it's
so easy to get shut down by Wesley and
not even get a chance to have enough uh
resources left on the board to create
something it's still a very rich middle
game white is weakened the king side the
white Bishop is on the queen side there
are potential Pawn weaknesses on the
board it's everything to play for
yep there's a lot of Chess left I think
objectively white is doing good here
um but but yeah there's a lot of Chess
left and um
and I do like the idea that you pointed
out telling you that those pollens are
overextended so if this Knight before
move continues to have good things
meaning let's say a trade every piece
that comes off the board when you've
overextended your pawns your space turns
into holes and your space turns into
weaknesses so Knight V4 he's on track
he's on track he's he's down a couple of
minutes but uh look we all want
Armageddon here okay we're all rooting
for I just you know you put me in a
position I can't I can't lie how I feel
about this position and my surprise
about how notabreck approaches so we'll
see
uh what's uh what's bigger for you right
now Danny your love for this position or
the the reading Armageddon oh my God
you're asking me like choose my kids
I'm regarding that's when that's when
tests wins don't tell Talia she's my
favorite don't tell her none of my kids
watch the show anyway
um no uh Armageddon is my favorite kid
you're right the only thing more
exciting is sudden death dodgeball we
all know that
about this whole bidding Armageddon
process because we didn't have that
before in the Chess World and it brings
a really exciting twist yeah as a sport
fan what do you think about it I love it
and I gotta give a shout out to the
events team
um Michael brancato the VP of Esports
and Greg shahadi actually works super
hard a lot of people know him as the
commissioner of the of the protest
league but Greg works with Michael on a
lot of the fun formats Robert has Donya
there's so much discussion and I don't
really remember whose idea it was I
think it's been done before of course in
longer Rapids but I think no one had
ever done the bidding in like Fast rapid
right and they and they really went all
in on it and um it's been so much so
much drama and so interesting so shout
out to all of them
evaluation bar just taking a bit of a
drop there actually after White's last
move is that uh yeah it's not as simple
as I I first thought I have to say yeah
it's gonna be I mean I think Tanya said
it very well and yourself Danny that
actually there's a lot of holes right
behind the paws and um there's a lot of
space there that maybe maybe white can
sort of get into at some point I agree
Johnny I mean you're right I mean now
okay A3 is interesting and then there's
C6 is going to come so he avoided that
nitrate like I was talking about when
you get C6 white will get kicked back so
there's a game here we got a game
everyone buckle up click in are you
gonna entertained
now we've got a game and A3 is nice and
sneaky it's a counter attack of course
Black's Knight is hanging on the B4
square but no time to go and take it
Black's threat is to capture on B2 with
this a pawn and White's rook in the
corner trapped so you have to decide do
you allow your structure to be
compromised or do you step forward but
then the black apron arry there is going
to be sitting for the rest of the game
super close to promotion any end game
will favor Black and uh yeah here we go
if black can make it that far looks
promising now suddenly yeah it's a very
weird scenario with the Knights as well
I mean these nights are confusing and I
I think uh it could be you know it could
be justified who gets the advantage on
how those Knights end up because at the
moment this Black Knight on the left
hand side maybe it's got to do something
it is now threatened and I think
capturing the center is possible but it
feels it feels again I think as as you
mentioned uh that white will only
improve his position if you take that
knight uh in the middle of the board
um and it's weird I'm looking at all the
pieces I mean also White's Bishop looks
disgusting fasting doesn't it I mean it
looks like a big Pawn who hasn't got out
of bed yet but I mean it might at some
point uh you know jump out of bed on
that long diagonal you know uh but it
doesn't look good at the moment so it's
a very strange position to evaluate not
as easier certainly as I first thought
and I prefer this move this seems like a
much better idea not not changing the
structure for White's benefit there and
you know with with C6 coming as well and
the queen yes it's actually very rich
yeah position exactly what Danny said
the trade happens on Black's terms here
this time and uh Suddenly It's All About
This Night caging these two pieces this
night if it stays there forever you can
even cement it later on uh if you need
to uh if it stays here then it will
paralyze at least one or two of the
white pieces you know I'm obviously
again the the scotch player in me has to
kick in and get biased and ask where did
it go wrong so let's back up a couple
moves because I feel like the alpha zero
Airy Pawn really is showing its strength
here and I'm wondering why did Wesley
allow that like okay why did Wesley play
A3 here it's like in instead of Knight
ed5 I feel like this was the right idea
to kick the Knight and after the night
moves whether you go Knight D5 or even
go after the a pawn like Bishop back to
C2 like
I'm surprised that that Wesley kind of
laid down and and just you know let the
Apon do its thing so
um anyway objectively I wanted to figure
that out just because you know I want to
understand as someone who kind of plays
these positions from time to time when
he still plays chess so I think that
this was a big mistake letting the pawn
get all the way it's still this is fun
it's equal and and we're rooting for
Armageddon so go Notre back but I think
A3 was Wesley's best move and we could
see the edge would have been maintained
there yeah especially after the dawn of
alpha zero as you mentioned Danny IT
players are really aware they're super
sensitive to those Pawn pushers so very
surprising that Wesley kind of allowed
it to continue marching down the board
and now Queen to F6 keeping an eye on
this dark Square diagonal really nice
move boy it's King Tanya you called it I
was skeptical but you called it White's
King feels a bit loose here and right
now we're seeing a lot of play on The
Queen side but don't be surprised if in
a couple of moves it does shift to the
king side because of the over extension
of white spawns and that's the only way
that white can untangle all that's going
on on the queen Side by trading this
bishop for the night is that a trade
that you would go for in this position
if you asked me a few minutes ago I
would have said yeah get rid of that
white light Square Bishop but now it
doesn't look like a great piece in Tanya
you mentioned it threats against the
white king Black's Bishop is threatening
to jump out with a check on H3 white
Rook would have been a Target so it
moves forward but yeah yeah it feels
loose for white it feels like he's
somehow becomes in the air feels loose
right like you're you're looking at your
Bug House partner and you're like Pawn
mates or you know you know Knight on D4
or Pawn on D I don't even know but like
there's holes if you could just fill
them with pieces right and so
unfortunately for black they only have a
couple minor pieces here there's no
obvious solution to getting in on the
squares but yeah it feels it feels
tender I'd love to see this Rook A5
again because obviously we love that
move because Wesley used this move
didn't he in there I think in that game
where he went through against uh Edward
and I I just love the idea of these very
weird Rook swings I I mean it's probably
not right because you're lining up on
the same line as the queen but you you
want to go for the king you want to
bring more pieces in it's not completely
crazy uh and uh it'd just be yeah be
nice to see this as a theme of the day
that that Rook swinging in but probably
probably not working so well here I love
it the Practical idea yeah it would
scare Wesley that's for sure for another
piece if I'm talking about about about
Scotch ideas and the ones that I know
well I'll also talk about a game I lost
horribly one of my worst launches losses
ever as white in the scotch was was to
an idea like Rook A5 in a big game too
and I just got very similar to this
where the momentum quickly shifted to
the king side and an overextended Pawn
chain left my king exposed and uh
it's okay it's a lot of trauma in the
studio that we need to get past
especially with the scotch opening yeah
and uh Simon you mentioned bringing the
Rook into the party he does it he starts
with the King side Rook first lining up
lining it up on the open E Line at some
point that e-born can be tender once
again I'm a little worried about
norderbeck's time management we've often
seen the critical moments arrive and
he's just not got enough time and then
sort of messing it up then created his
chances he's done everything right so
far he's managed to get something out of
the opening but is clock going to be a
factor in this one as well
I think it has to be it's been a
manufacturer in all of them and I think
that what you're calling attention to
Tanya was
was reminding me of the point I was
making about how norterbeck looked
versus Magnus remember we only didn't
get a fourth game because Notre Beck his
nerves got the best of him he didn't
convert and I feel like again the time
management suggests that he's just
looked a little nervous you know um in
some of these games and and
and I agree
yeah and also this type of opening we
saw it previously when Wesley played
against titurizaga from the black side
against this maroxy bind that we've been
highlighting it takes time the onus is
on you the burden is on you to break out
and uh often that's yeah that shows
later on in the game as it did with
itarizaga meanwhile okay he's just
started to up the speed up the pace he's
brought his Rook to d8 maybe hinting at
a breakout in the center we've been
talking about finally pushing to break
the maroxy bind he's hinting I'm not so
sure it's gonna work but I like what
he's been doing he just needs to do it
quicker and now it's time for Wesley
surely to bring his Rook into the game
that rook in the corner it's E1 D1
choices I really like the way Wesley's
brought his Bishop around towards his
King side uh you know Wesley very alert
there realizing his King was actually
Stein Stein's become a bit of a Target
and that that poor Bishop who was in bed
on the other side at least has found a
better bed now he's found a more
comfortable bed where it actually
defends the king and uh and actually the
white king looking pretty safe you know
at this moment in time it's only if uh
uh some some things get exchanged off
that it could be and the Rooks get in
now could be in any danger at all so I
think again Wesley's Wesley's looking
alright at the moment or pretty safe
maybe a Tempur-Pedic mattress find a new
bad Tempur-Pedic what are you are you a
soft mattress guy are you a hard man
you know what any kind of mattress is
good for me they can imagine any kind of
mattress for a little harder mattress
yeah back support have you ever tried a
waterbed I can see you and your water
bed you know chess.com okay wait a
second okay
F5
I'm surprised by that move that is very
committal it's always slightly
anti-positional but it's got a direct
idea in mind a specific idea of trading
off the Queens maybe it's forced now if
the Queens come off maybe he thinks he's
safe there Wesley he wants the end game
he wants a draw he's playing with house
money right now he only needs a half
point
maybe that was a really opportune moment
to push forward the F Pawn we say it's
in kind of anti-positional here it's not
what you want usually because you give
away squares now White Center is much
more static but it's like the queens and
the Bishops are forced off the board
there we go very quickly snapped off
there and what are we left with we're
left with black and weak Pawn on D6
to break up I ate my words in the last
game when I when I thought Wesley played
E4 in the in the game that he eliminated
charizaga and he was right to go to that
end game and maybe now F5 seems
anti-positional but if he only needs a
draw he's headed to the end game
that makes a lot of sense given the math
situation Wesley so we'll go on to the
Grand Final if he's able to get a draw
in this one and we've been talking about
that a pawn which was a big strength
clamping down White's Queen side within
many end games it can also be a weakness
that just falls apart I can imagine the
night retreating and then suddenly black
doesn't have enough resources to defend
all the weaknesses on the board yeah
just to point out your idea Tanya maybe
it's a threat in this position as well
and okay he doesn't go for it uh because
yeah the black Rook is tied down to this
point it doesn't have time to go and
defend uh that a pawn really yeah let's
keep an eye on that one for later on
meanwhile distraction he's trying to
play on the king side suddenly let's
catch up with the game he trying to take
this Pawn is he or is he just hinting
super stuck I think white has Tanya's
idea in mind I think Wesley brought the
king up because if you move the Knight
to B1 earlier the E4 Pawn would have
been weak right so Wesley correctly
activates the king first to guard E4 and
Tanya's Knight B1 I think is going to
come into play here
he needs to get his Rooks active here
Abdu Satora if he gains some space he
pushes his H Pawn but yeah this looks
very tempting now and I think the point
is that rat can actually move the rook
and get it to defend the a pawn because
White's got to be careful about picking
up the d-pawn don't forget if the a pawn
Falls that's super uh good for black to
get the a pawn rolling
so white would love to avoid this if
possible the one downside is that after
your Rook moves maybe white just goes
back and you cannot repeat the position
now you're forced to defend this point
oh that's a good point oh what he's
playing what's he played here whoa
breaking through be fine what in the
world Wesley so going for the kill I
quite like that he's just Lisa
oh okay
therapy I have to get more therapy the
PTSD this this is the idea behind the
big breakthrough is not a sacrifice
because this Pawn is poisoned if you
take it a nasty check will deflect the
black king and suddenly no defense of
the Rook it's only defended once it's
attacked twice and white would emerge
with an extra Rook here beautiful
beautiful tactic and okay nordebec has
had to capture this Pawn instead but
look at the wreckage of his structure
this is one-way traffic suddenly Wesley
in control
beautiful Wesley's in control and uh his
uh his his comeback The Comeback tour
starring Wesley so continues
you quoted a few days ago Danny after
his uh after his win just what was it
two days ago you said he's coming back
he's playing great chess isn't he I mean
just the quality has got so much better
every day a bit I mean if Wesley so does
win this match that's just uh remind
everyone he's gonna be playing against
Magnus in the final and yesterday Magnus
was asked who would you like to play and
he said Wesley and why did he say Wesley
because he thought that would be the
toughest final and the closest final I
feel and uh you know Magnus loves a
challenge though I mean that'll be some
final and I mean really really we're not
there yet but I agree I think I think so
yeah yeah so on form is a tough
challenge for Magnus and he knows it and
and that's going to be a battle tomorrow
yeah
and meanwhile you're right here on the
board Tanya that white knight dropped
back forcing the black Rook to go to A8
and look at the black Brooks both just
totally immobilized one as a blockader
the other one just defending a mere Pawn
looks like White's Rooks can start
entering shortly maybe there's other
ways to finesse it white Knight's gonna
come back yeah I like that night
maneuver David maybe you can move move
that Knight where the king is but all
these ideas looking really good for
white now Black's Rooks don't want to be
on those squares the black rugs cannot
get active now the Black Knight kind of
looks alright but it also can't get
active and White's Rooks are ready to
dive in and that's a scary Pawn right in
the middle of the board one square from
queening it's not looking good at the
moment for Naughty Becky it's hard
because that Nano B4 Keeps The Rook on
D2 tied down but that means it can't do
anything else right you kind of wish the
Knight was involved if you move the
Knight to A6 then white is free to play
Rook D6 check and right and and here we
go King takes F5 so 90 mentioned it that
was the center of the board on e4 we
might be singing a different tune right
now but there's no thoughts there and
notice how that seatbon actually really
does take away squares he listens to
your Danny says it's time he does it but
I think Rook D6 I was I was sort of
advising not to do that because Here
Comes Rook D6 check and I don't see a
reason why I can't just yeah check and
yeah but the problem is there's even
going to be perpetuals I feel you know
because all the blacks pieces are on the
wrong side of the board and you know
even if you don't even need to win this
position as white a draw is good enough
to go through King E7 I think the only
move here and keep a bit of pressure if
you get your knight to E6 I was just
gonna say if Wesley maybe doesn't need
to take the pawn maybe he should get the
night back in the game you can swing The
Rook over to H6 at some point I would
look at Knight C3 here okay he does take
it
active King active King for the win yeah
but the d-pawn is going to fall what
does Wesley have up his sleeve while the
evaluation bar reacted big time there uh
it looked like a very natural move to me
he's going for White's very far Advanced
past Pawn there but yeah what is the
idea Wesley finds it what is it I think
he's just gonna go C5 at the right oh
you just play C5 and black is frozen
yeah Let It Go Elsa and your other rook
and rock and roll then as well see yeah
nice one so in the camera
What's Happening Here it looks like
black is going to take this Pawn but
we'll see yeah a demonstration of
domination here if the Knight does take
this Pawn then assignment says just lock
it down now everything is protected
black is ultimately pinned if you move
your knight that all the Rooks will
disappear and white will be winning that
end game simply this Pawn would fall as
well you cannot even activate this Rook
because white will just defend
everything this white is Knight is
coming back into the game and that will
spell the end
plus now that the work on D6 is defended
by the pond you have rookie one check in
a lot of positions and and then it's
just Perpetual rookie one king f8 Rook
D1 just like you can't do anything right
so that just ends ends it on the spot
clinical stuff amazing play by Wesley so
throughout today starting from his uh
loser semi-final to this match felt like
a Wesley saw show throughout and notepad
never really got going he never got his
chances in this match no I mean Wesley's
just been too strong
um he's played so well throughout I mean
there's been maybe that you know that
first game as Edward said of the day
Edward got some chances in time
scrambled but he wasn't even better in
that position
um this move I'm a little bit surprised
about does this give black some chances
because uh he really could have shut
that night down I don't think so but uh
Wesley's just played fantastic and he's
getting better and better every day
um if he does get a final against Magnus
it's going to be a very hard one to call
that one gonna be a really fun one
because that's one final we haven't seen
yet in the Champions Chester Magnus
Carlsen taking on Wesley he still needs
to draw this game to get there but right
now it's white with all the trumps in
the position
the night the night's going to come into
C3 I think Rook D5 here is Rook D5
I don't really want to chase the Black
Knight to E6 though so I'm just kind of
like let's play Knight C3 and that guy's
been patiently waiting for a square to
develop too
yeah bring the last piece to that party
and yes black might win the d-pawn but
that will only uh end up in some trades
and I think white has got at least a
draw in his pocket there
so Wesley just mulling over also the
clock Advantage he's got the luxury of
just sitting there for three four
minutes calculating his way to at least
a draw or position that's very safe in
order back with 20 seconds just reacting
and at this point it's not going to be
enough a win is a distant dream I think
that was the right call there good call
there Danny the Knight joins the attack
he takes the pawn and it's a big mistake
is there a finish here David
it's something to do with Knight D5 and
the B6 squares calling my name I'm
freaking out what is it take everything
take once and go Knight D5 and then yeah
just take one to 95 and then if the King
goes to the D file they'd be six and
Wesley he leaves because
offer that was made and Wesley just
accepts it not a back played Rook D7 it
is a dead lost situation but he just
offered a draw yeah he'd given up hope
he knew it was hopeless on the board he
knew he was actually losing this
position and decided to get out of there
surprising we used we're used to seeing
players play to the better end but
yeah just uh pragmatism there means he's
out though
not a bug is out of the game chess rapid
and Wesley so it does it for the second
time today he books his spot into the am
chess rapid Grand Final against Magnus
Carlsen and what a show he's put on
after a tough start on a Monday day one
of the aim chest rap and he's won every
single mad since in two matches today
it's really what the Wesley social what
was the highlight for you David several
highlights here Tanya and just to point
out two moments that clinched it for
Wesley that sealed his path to the Grand
Final here we were talking about Black
coming back into the game White's King
slightly Airy this Black Knight very
active but this move F5 out of the blue
traded off the queens and forced a very
safe position this tension is just too
much because Black's Queen is needed to
guard the bishop and once Queens came
off once Bishops came off Wesley was
able to work his magic if we fast
forward to the final position to show
why nordebec had given up hope we also
see that after taking this Pawn a simple
Rook trade as Simon was mentioning a
night check here been deadly the black
king lacks good squares it might have to
retreat to a square like this one but
yeah this knight jump now would have
ended the game pretty much this Rook is
attacked this Knight is attacked and
black would barely be able to survive a
few more moves
a lot of performance there by Wesley saw
joining that last game he always had it
together in fact he could have pushed
for more but it wasn't required because
take a look at the score line and what a
day of Chess we've had in the
elimination bracket we started with the
loser semi-final a big fight by through
zaga but Wesley so won the first game
and joined the second one seal the deal
he went on to play not the back up to
Saturn starts with a win a dominating
performance in this match against uh not
the back by Wesley there and that means
we get the final that we've been waiting
for in the Champions Chester a final
that mattress Carlson is looking forward
to as well as he takes on Wesley so and
wesiso will have to beat Magnus twice
tomorrow to become the champion and
that's not an easy ask it's not an easy
ask but this is the final that we've
been waiting for I mean it's I'm like
clear your schedules tomorrow's a Friday
right call in sick this is it you got
Wesley so with his chance
to punch his ticket to Toronto Magnus
asked for it he said I want Wesley and
uh let's go I'm excited it's gonna be a
really fun match David yeah and these
two have history Wesley so has beaten
Magnus actually several times before in
the Champions chess tour back in season
one he beat him twice in finals so he
has formed Magnus knows how dangerous
Wesley is is gonna be fire
hi Moon
that's gonna be a big one yeah I mean
it's gonna be an uphill challenge but um
he's done it before he's beaten Magnus
on occasions and uh it's kind of two of
the best players fighting against each
other in a quick format it's gonna be uh
it's just going to be a great match
tomorrow I mean I I really don't know
who to pick I mean Magnus is playing so
well but Wesley's just getting better
and better every game so it's going to
be very exciting it's gonna be great
chess tomorrow and it was great just
today by Wesley so and he is joining us
Wesley congratulations hey guys yeah
thank you very much with a very very
exciting day for for me at least
it was actually yeah go on Wesley
yeah I mean I just want to mention
it's like the apologize now they beg for
not I mean I completely got thrown in
the first game like any when he played
Bishop B5 I was gonna offer him a take
back but there's no take back
on chess.com so uh I actually want to
play Bishop P4 but I figured maybe
bishop B5 is not that stupid
but uh yeah I just completely got
through that one you were smiling a lot
at that point and it was really fun to
watch the reaction what was going on in
your mind then
well I I thought he must sleep
I really wanted to play Bishop C4 and uh
uh I guess you know another Beck's very
happy to qualify for the next tournament
but I thought the games today were kind
of serious and to play that
on the second move takes a lot of
Courage for him so kudos to that and
actually he got a very good position
like it's very difficult mentally when
your opponent throws you I remember when
Magnus played the bonecloud against me
in a Blitz game
um
two years ago
and I lost that game so I mean black
should be better but uh it's not easy
when you haven't seen that position
before also mentally to adjust now
you're not sure whether you should pay
for a win and also if you lose it's
gonna be very embarrassing and another
break was actually quite close in the
end it's just a very good practical
player he put up a lot of pressure on me
just making moves so quickly
it was a great fight and Wesley you
started the aim chess drafted a little
shaky lost the first match went into the
losers bracket here but since then
you've just been playing Amazing chess
what switched because you're just on
fire now
oh well thank you well uh I
wanted to join the interview Studio at
least once
for that uh but
um yeah also it's uh very interesting I
mean I
probably should have won the first match
against and then I probably should have
lost the match against fedo seals and
or probably should also Blossom match
against Fabiano so I in the end
I think the format is very interesting
because you have one
bad game then you still have chances to
come back so uh
when I first heard about the format
earlier this year I wasn't sure but now
having two lives is uh it's very
interesting and I I just took it a game
at the time you know trying not not to
do anything strenuous in between the
rounds try not to prepare too much but
just come up and play
but Wesley um it's been it's been a joy
to watch and and uh I've always said a
confident a confident Wesley so usually
means an on form Wesley so and an
on-form Wesley so
beat Magnus Carlson and Oslo in 2019 was
a global champion last year and maybe
his maybe he's playing the best chess in
the world when he when he's on form so
how do you feel heading into tomorrow in
a match against Magnus Carlson given the
momentum you seem to have found
uh
uh yeah I mean it's going to be tough to
win to matches in a row and also he won
his first nine games in Blitz in Croatia
and I think he also won title choose the
late title Tuesday the other day
with uh nine was it like 10 out of 11
something like that I watched the full
stream
so
yeah again the usual just
try to play my best chess and uh
hope that uh
it gives me some
chances I mean Magnus is only human he
can have an off day offer from time to
time
and uh
you know I mean first of all I'm happy
to qualify for the next event that was
my main goal
but uh yeah I've lost way too many
matches against Magnus Carlson in the
past so
things have to be things should be
different at some point hopefully
tomorrow will be the day but
I'd like to thank you again Danny for
always believing in me even when
sometimes I don't believe in myself so I
really appreciate that
well it's going to be a very exciting
match tomorrow and we're all looking
forward to it Wesley and uh yesterday
when Magnus was asked uh who he'd like
to play in the final he he did he did
mention your name so uh
um I guess as he really wants to
challenge himself with the best have you
got any thoughts on that at all
any yeah well I guess he beat oh they're
back already quite convincingly
and uh you know he he didn't
he didn't want to play the same one but
uh
yeah I mean it's it's uh fascinating I
always enjoyed watching uh Magnus
Carlson's game so it's uh
it's a big honor for me to play against
him you know I've been studying his
games over the last few years and you
can always learn something new from any
of these games
but again I I think you know if you lose
like 10 matches against Magnus in a row
at some point you gotta have a win
lastly it's going to be a fantastic
Grand Final and we're so excited about
the matchup tomorrow congratulations for
a phenomenal day of Chess winning two
matches and we look forward to the
action between you and Magnus tomorrow
yeah thank you I'm just very fortunate
to still be at this stage
and uh yeah also big congratulations to
my opponents today uh for Eduardo for
playing so well also for no they're back
again playing Bishop B5 and second
movies yes
truthful of Courage
absolutely Wesley thank you so much for
joining us all the best for tomorrow
thank you
Wesley so there with some really nice
words for his opponent he's got to be
one of the nicest guys on the circuit
he's just he's just so sweet and he's
kind and he always goes out of his way
to just thank people and and that's
really who he is he's just he's humble
and and at times I think Wesley's
problem as I've talked him about medical
evidence is confidence it's the other
way right the fact that he is so humble
and so kind I think keeps him in that
mindset at times it's the confidence
that he really needs
yeah the thing is you can't poke the
bear if you wake Wesley up and it looks
like he's woken up now then he's one of
the most dangerous customers out there
face of an Angel but on the chessboard
he's a killer
stirs a lot we've got to talk about and
discuss ahead of this graph
[Music]
the most elite bullet tournament returns
you don't want to miss the fourth ever
bullet Chess Championship featuring
Magnus Carlson for the first time he'll
join reigning champ Hikaru Nakamura 2021
champion alireza ferrugia and more to
fight for their share of the 100 000
prize fund it all kicks off on July 17th
at 9am Pacific
use exclamation point BCC in chat for
all the details
next Monday July 17th the bullets Chess
Championship begins where 16th of the
world's greatest hits chess players well
content for the bullet chess Crown will
Hikaru defend his reign will feruja
block his path and take back the title
he held just two years ago and will
Magnus bccw shake up the field entirely
submit your bullets Chess Championship
bracket now for chance to win 6 months
of diamond membership use comment
fantasy in the chat bracket submission
close on July 17th when game 1 of the
BCC kicks off
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
want to improve your game click the link
in the chess.com navigation bar to try
aim chest today and increase your rating
31 faster than standard tactics puzzles
when you sign up for aim chess our
powerful AI breaks down your latest
games and provides actionable insights
to immediately improve your game you
will also receive personalized lessons
created from your game history to help
you learn from your mistakes in a custom
made study plan to help you reach your
goals learn chess your way with aim
chess your digital chess coach
got stronger faster with aim chess
analytics and lessons and you get your
first month free with the code
cctgo.chess.com
aim chess it's been an exciting day of
Chess here in the elimination bracket
we've had so much fun and daddy rumor
has it that you've been having a lot of
fun in Oslo we've been maybe having too
much fun in Oslo I love Oslo and the
weather's been beautiful we've got a lot
of time outside and uh we got to catch
up with with a bunch of a bunch of fans
of Magnus Carlsen and of Chess in
general and Oslo on a on a beautiful
Saturday right after arriving and uh
there's some of the stuff we got into
do you know who Magnus Carlson is yes
who is Magnus
he's a chess player I think he's a
champion yeah yeah a world champion Joe
Magnus Carlson is yes
and who's the greatest chess player of
all time
Magnus Carlson right you know Magnus
Carlson is of course you know that she's
met Magnus Carlton I met him I did yeah
nice he was the world chess champion and
I am wearing his shoes are you Magnus
Carls I am Magnus Carlson I'm not Magnus
I mean I wish you were I know I wish I
was too hey sir do you like my shoes I
think they're awesome first of all how
sexy are these shoes 10 yeah one to ten
I'll say eight eight point six okay yeah
I like this goldish
color that's what I saw who can you
guess by looking at him whose shoes they
are some chess guy some chess guy when
you look at these shoes these are Magnus
Carlson's shoes ah okay so therefore
they are the best therefore they are the
best that's right who's the greatest
chess player of all time it's Magnus
Carlson right what if I told you I took
these shoes right off his feet oh you
did yeah is it real
take a look get close these are Magnus
Carlson limited edition Clyde suede
shoes from Puma would you take shoes off
of Magnus Carlson's feet if you could
get away with it
okay come on thank you for your time
also Norway we love you
[Music]
that was a lot of fun there's actually
even more content even more content
coming but it was great to see a lot of
people when you when you're wearing
Magnus Carlsen shoes around here they
just accept you as one of their own they
don't look at you as an awkward American
on the street so that was fun it's
strange I mean like everyone in Norway
who knows life seems to know Magnus
Carlson right it's crazy like it's so
popular here chess I mean you you talk
to anyone who's Magnus Carson even that
even that uh woman there she's like I've
met Magnus I know Magnus is crazy some
people even knew David although that
content I might be teasing that for
tomorrow so we'll see what people
thought David did when we talk to them
not as many people knew me I can uh
reveal that now
humble that by David but Magnus Carlson
he's of course the big star here in
Norway and while we know it's going to
be Wesley so taking on Magnus in that
division one Grand Final Ketty we also
know our finalists in division two
that's right it is Danny's lasovic 17
years old who won the Armageddon with
black pieces he choose 10 minutes but he
totally outplayed his opponent Savion
tomorrow he will face Jose Martinez who
had himself a great day he won two
matches first match against kamski
second match against huckabian and he is
ready to fight for the ticket to the
division one one of these two players
either Dennis or Jose will get this
ticket and ten thousand dollars there is
so much on the line for these two
players fighting it out in the Grand
Final then last was is Jose Martinez one
of them will qualify for division one of
the next Champions Chester event a huge
payday with 10K on the line and the tour
points Katie it's gonna be a big day of
exciting chess throughout the divisions
and what do you have for us in division
three in division three we have very
interesting situation because we have
two Vietnamese Grand Masters tomorrow
fighting against each other mainly and
Lee Liam kind of um gonna fight it out
and one of these two players will face
yuyangi in the grand finals and we're
gonna know who will be the player who
will win 5 000 dollars
yuyangi is waiting for that Grand Final
it's going to be a big fight tomorrow it
is the final day of the aim chess rapid
let's take a look at our bracket going
into that big Grand Final there Wesley
so has to beat Magnus Carlsen twice that
is a big psychological battle apart from
being a battle on the board how does
Wesley get by what does he need to do
tomorrow David well Wesley has done it
before and often that does involve
hitting Magnus in the opening catching
him uh unawares and it's not going to be
easy as you say Tanya but I think in
this four in this first four game match
he needs to strike early Magnus often
holds the lead once he gets there you
can't take it back so it's the first
game or two where I think it will be
critical yeah it's going to be really
tough though I mean you've got to win
not once but twice because Magnus has
won all of his matches so far but he
does have a chance he's done it before
and he's just got to play at his normal
standard his standard today and see what
happens I think you made a great Point
David that you have to strike early
against Magnus or at least not lose
early right and I think that actually
plays doubly on the players we have here
one because Magnus is so good at
protecting his lead we've seen him do it
and also I think Wesley so on form as I
said is a confident Wesley so and if his
confidence gets shaken
things might fall apart right so I think
for Wesley not losing is critical
it's going to be a fantastic day of
Chess and we've had such incredible
storylines right now it is about Kan
Wesley so take down Magnus Carlsen twice
but also Eduardo terizaga what a moment
this has been for him what a platform
named chess rapid has been for him I
admit I'm I'm super excited to see
Wesley in the Grand Final and it was
kind of the matchup I was thinking would
happen given the form we were watching
with Wesley but I'm upset that Eduardo
didn't make the final of the losers
bracket because it means he doesn't have
a guaranteed spot into division one next
time so we're not going to have him here
there but shout out to Eduardo vamos
Eduardo and we'll see you again
Eduardo and he has won so many hearts
and as you said Danny he will be
fighting in the planes for the next
event so he's looking for that spot as
well and we've got some great news
you've got a winner from our air things
contest there and that is the winning
answer King to F5 wins because the night
our King cannot hold Harry but David and
Simon with a big smile there and nothing
to see here wins this very cool add
things wave plus device so with magnus's
signature it's the one that David and
Magnus had on with them congratulations
a well done Simon Harry the H Bond he
said
it's good to see that Harry's getting
the accolades that he justly deserves
yeah good old Harry
a good old Mac
Donald that is a grand final you don't
want to miss we'll be back with all the
action we'll see you then
Mind Games
goes on to the losers final
[Laughter]
Wesley so it does it for the second time
today he books his spot into the M chess
rapid Grand Final against Magnus Carlsen
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you